l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement et la première d'entre ell
va être posée par Monsieur le Président
mat pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
démocrate merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre ces derniers
jours nombre d'entre nous avons vu avec
inquiétude se multiplier sur les réseaux
sociaux les tags antisémites partout en
France cela nous rappelle avec horreur
les temps de la peur que nous croyons
disparu cette peur est ressentie
aujourd'hui par nombre de familles de
confessions juives avec la
multiplication des actes antisémites
depuis le 7 octobre dernier pour l'année
2015 nous déplorions 808 actes
antisémites au cours de ces trois
dernières semaines ces 850 actes ont été
qui ont été commis en France plus de
6000 messages sur les réseaux sociaux
ont fait l'objet d'un signalement sur
Faros en réponse 430 personnes ont été
interpellées 234 enquêtes ont été
ouvertes la réponse de l'État est forte
et nous la saluons mais au-delà la
réponse pénale nous députés démocrates
sommes alarmés sur ce que cette
recrudescence de l'antisémitisme dit de
notre société car l'antisémitisme agit
comme un canari dans la mine l'arabin
Delphine orvilleer nous le rappelle la
frénésie antisémite révèle les failles
de notre nation dans l'esprit malade des
antisémites les Français de confession
juifes sont et ne seront jamais des que
des juifs et non des citoyens ce faisant
la passion antisémite s'attaque au
fondement même de notre nation
l'antisémitisme est une insulte à notre
histoire à nos principes républicains à
la cohésion nationale sans prendre un
juif c'est offenser la République c'est
attaquer la
France de la même façon tout acte qui
vise à condamner l'autre à l'agresser
pour ce qu'il est pour sa religion pour
son origine est insupportable pour notre
pays madame la Première ministre face à
ce fléo quelle réponse pouvons-nous
apporter non pas en tant qu'État mais
comme nation je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le président Jean-Paul
matthi des slogans aineux sur des
banderoles des commentaires odieux sur
les réseaux sociaux des menaces des
insultes et parfois des coups
l'antisémitisme à de multiples visages
tous aussi
insupportables depuis les attaques
terroristes du 7 octobre contre Israël
les manifestations de haine se sont
intensifié plus de 850 incidents ont eu
lieu et près de 6000 signalements en
ligne ont été réalisés ces derniers
jours à saint-toin à Paris au
petitquevilli les habitants ont
découvert des T des tags antisémites sur
les murs de leur ville des étoiles de
David ou des des croix gamés comme une
évocation glaçante du passé au nom du
gouvernement je condamne avec une
fermeté absolue ces agissements
ignobles
l'antisémitisme c'est la lâcheté la
haine de l'autre et tous ceux qui se
rendent coupables de ces actes doivent
être interpellés et
condamnés la France s'est construite
depuis plus de 200 ans comme une terre
de liberté d'ouverture et de tolérance
s'ans prendre à quelqu'un parce qu'il
est juif c'est s'en prendre à nos
valeurs les plus fortes c'est s'en
prendre à ce qui nous rassemble c'est
s'en prendre à la même de la République
rien ne peut être toléré justifié ou
excusé depuis le 7 octobre nous avons
redoublé d'efforts le ministre de
l'Intérieur a immédiatement passé des
consignes de vigilance au préfet et aux
forces de l'ordre la sécurisation des
lieux sensibles les écoles les lieux de
culte a été renforcé les enquêtes avance
et la justice est ferme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président mat d'ors et déjà
plus de 430
interpellations et plus de 230 enquêtes
en cours nous ne laisserons rien passer
depuis ce 7 octobre les Juifs de France
connaissent le poids de l'angoisse alors
je veux leur dire avec mon gouvernement
et je n'en doute pas avec vous nous
sommes à vos côtés nous nous le
resterons rien ne justifie la haine et
la violence c'est notre c'est le devoir
de notre pays de le combattre c'est le
devoir de la République de protéger tous
les Juifs de France et vous pouvez
compter sur mon engagement sans faille
je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première
ministre la parole est à Madame Sandrine
Rousseau pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des Affaires étrangères Catherine Colona
madame la ministre la France en tant que
état tiersre au conflit
israélo-palestinien doit avoir une
position claire elle renoué avec son
rôle historique consistant à défendre le
droit international tout le droit
international rien que le droit
international celui-ci
exige la libération sans condition de
tous les otages civil la protection de
toutes les personnes civiles la mise en
place en urgence d'un corridor
humanitaire permettant d'acheminer les
produits de première nécessité dont les
médicaments la levée complète du blocus
de la Bande de Gaza l'accès de la presse
pour informer sans entrave et témoigner
de ce qui se passe là-bas en ce sens
lors de l'Assemblée générale des Nations
unies réunies vendredi dernier la France
a voté une résolution largement adopté
demandant une trêve humanitaire
immédiate durable et soutenue menant à
la cessation des
activités des hostilités pardon la
communauté internationale et la France
mon sil vous plî RC depis plusieurs
années à fa appliquer le droit
international laissant ainsi la région
se gangraer le cycle de la violence
s'amplifier nous devons agir en
responsabilité madame la ministre alors
que l'armée israélienne attaque en ce
moment même Gaza par voie terrestre
tuant la population civile
3195 enfants morts et mettant en danger
les otages détenu par le Hamas quelles
sont les pressions que la France
envisage enfin de afin de mettre un TER
à cet enfer pouvez-vous madame la
ministre affirmer aujourd'hui devant
l'Assemblée nationale que la France
appelle à l'instar d'Antonio gterz cess
le feu
humanitaire je vous remercie la parole
est à Madame Laurence B secrétaire
d'État chargé de
l'Europe merci madame la Présidente
d'abord je vous prexcuser ministre
Europe et des Affaires étrangères
kenrine Colona qui participe à Turin au
comité de coopération transfrontalière
du Traité du
kirinal madame la députée c'estandrine
Rousseau vous avez dit que la France
doit agir en responsabilité et vous avez
raison c'est précisément ce que fait
notre
diplomatie c'est d'abord en
responsabilité que la France agit au
plan politique vous l'avez rappelé la
France a voté en faveur du texte
jordanien présenté à l'Assemblée
générale des Nations Unies
texte qui appelait à la mise en place
d'une trêve humanitaire menant à
l'association des hostilités c'est la
position de la France depuis les
premiers jours de ce conflit c'est aussi
la position commune des Européens
exprimés la semaine dernière c'est un
responsabilité également que la France
agit dans le domaine humanitaire au 20
millions d'euros débloqués pour les
agences internationales et les ONG
s'ajoute notre frais humanitaire au
bénéfice du Croissant Rouge égyptien et
le soutien que nous allons apporter à
l'hôpital jordanien de Gaza c'est un
impératif et l'aide doit être acheminée
en quantité suffisante et de manière
durable c'est en responsabilité
également que nous cherchons avec nos
partenaires dans la région et au-delà un
chemin qui évite un embrasement régional
et permette de tracer une perspective de
paix le déplacement du président de la
République les deux tournées de
Catherine Colona dans la région notre
notre action au Conseil de sécurité en
vue de l'adoption d'une résolution ont
aussi cet objectif c'est enfit en
responsabilité que nous rappelons des
principes simples la condamnation du
terrorisme du Hamas et des crimes
abjects qu'il a commis le droit d'Israël
à la sécurité et son devoir d'agir dans
le cadre du droit international et enfin
évidemment l'impérieuse nécessité d'un
horizon politique pour que les
Palestiniens et les Israéliens puisse
vivre dans deux états côte à côte et en
paix je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la
ministre je vais en profiter pour saluer
la présence dans l'hémicycle de famille
et pour leur dire que nous sommes à leur
côté depuis l'attaque terroriste du 7
octobre dernier nous déplorons la mort
de 35 de nos
compatriotes cela fait aujourd'hui 25
jours que ne français sont tenu en
otage leurs familles sont donc présentes
et je vous
remercie au nom de la représentation
nationale de leur dire collectivement
que nous sommes à leur
côté
[Applaudissements]
et je ne doute pas que le gouvernement
fera tout ce qui est dans son possible
pour obtenir la libération de vos
proches le plus rapidement possible
merci à tous
la parole est à Monsieur Paul mollac
pour le groupe
lot merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Agriculture monsieur le ministre le
groupe lot se félicite du maintien des
prix agricoles qui remunè mieux nos
agriculteurs toutefois certains
problèmes demeurent je veux tout d'abord
évoquer les retards de paiement de la
pack qui touche certains agriculteurs
près de 500 dossiers concernés dans le
Gers autre sujet la crainte de certaines
filières face aux importations de pays
tiers tels que l'Australie je souhaite
également évoquer les difficultés de nos
agriculteurs qui se sont engagés dans la
transition écologique les bios en
premier lieu qui souffrent d'une
contraction du marché et de la nécessité
de faire appliquer la loi sur la
restauration collective mais le cœur de
ma question concerne ici les mesures
dites agro-environnemental et climatique
plus communément dénommé Maek elles sont
un outil majeur de la transition
agroécologique elles incitent au
changement des pratiques et de systèmes
en rémunérant les surcts et les prises
de risque nous sommes 35 parlementaires
bretons à l'initiative de notre collègue
Claudia rou à vous avoir interpellé
aujourd'hui les financements de l'État
sont largement insuffisants pour honorer
ces contrats selon région de France il
manquera entre 250 et 300 millions
d'euros vous comprendrez aisément que le
fait d'abandonner des exploitants
agricoles pourtant engagés dans des
mesures d'adaptation
agroécologique alors que l'on veut
baisser la consommation de produits
phyau de 50% comporte quelques
contradictions au moment où nous sommes
justement en train d'examiner les
crédits de la mission agriculture le
monde agricole qui agit en faveur de la
transition écologique vous écoute
monsieur le ministre l'état sera-t-il au
rendez-vous pour aider les agriculteurs
vertueux je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Marc fen ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Paul mollac
d'abord répondre sur la question des
paiements de la PAC nous sommes dans une
nouvelle période de programmation vous
vous souvenez sans doute de ce qui
s'était passé en 2015 quand nous étions
trouvé face à une très grande impasse je
vois que vous vous en souvenez
parfaitement nous sommes dans la
disposition d'avoir pu payer dès le le
16 octobre ça veut pas dire qu'il y a
pas un certain nombre de sujets de
dossier dans un certain nombre de
département mais nous sommes à un tau de
près de 90 % de dosser payés à la date
où je vous parle ne faisons pas des
exceptions qui sont des ennuis pour nous
aussi hein des règles général je crois
qu'on peut aussi se féliciter il faut
saluer les services des chambes
d'agriculture les syndicalismes
globalement et les services de l'État
qui sont au rendez-vous du paiement
d'une pack qui n'est pas la même que
celle que nous connaissions dans la
période complémentaire deuxième élément
vous dire sur la question de la
transition écologiques et les grandes
transitions il y a plusieurs dispositifs
dans la pack il y a la conversion à
l'agriculture biologique il y a les
dispositifs de l'écorégime et il y a les
mesures agrienvironnemental que vous
citez oui nous avons une difficulté en
particulier sur la Bretagne d'abord vous
rappelez que l'enveloppe qui est celle
des MAEC est la même elle est même en
légère augmentation que dans la
précédente programmation donc l'état est
au rendez-vous la différence c'est
qu'elles étaient gérées par les régions
désormais elles sont gérées par l'État
mais ce n'est pas ça le sujet le sujet
que nous avons désormais c'est un sujet
d'enveloppe qui
en particulier en Bretagne dépasse les
enveloppes qui avaient été prédéfinies y
compris avec les régions je rappelle que
ça n'est pas une logique de
guichet c'est une logique dans une
enveloppe de sélection de mesures
agréenvironnementales alors qu'est-ce
qu'il faut qu'on fasse dans le temps qui
nous est imparti puisqu'on est dans la
période de préprogrammation c'est de
faire en sorte qu'on regarde si tous les
financements qui devaient être mobilisés
je pense en particulier au financement
des agences de l'eau qui doivent mettre
70 millions d'euros supplémentaires par
an sur ces mesures environnementales
agrienvironnemental bien au rendez-vous
pour qu'on puisse couvrir les besoins
donc on regarde dans ce cadre là pour
faire en sorte vous avez raison sur ce
sujet là comme sur d'autres qu'on soit
bien au rendez-vous des attentes des
agriculteurs en tout cas vous pouvez
compter sur moi pour le faire et pour
sur le gouvernement comme on le fait
depuis le début sur ces sujets je vous
remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame
constance legrip pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur la bête immonde existe
toujours la bête immonde de
l'antisémitisme et elle exhale à nouveau
un souffle noséabon et ignoble la haine
des Juifs cette haine des Juifs peut
sembler prendre des habits neufs des
foné et l'antisionisme en é un de fauné
de plus en plus répandu dans les rues de
notre pays sur les réseaux sociaux dans
les universités peut-être même au sein
de partis politiques représentés dans
cet hémicycle mais c'est toujours la
même haine alimentée main par
l'islamisme la haine d'Israël et le
complottisme depuis le 7 octobre ce sont
840 actes antisémites qui ont été
recensé dans notre pays 430 personnes
interpellées 840 actes antisémites en 3
semaines soit beaucoup beaucoup plus que
durant l'année écoulée c'est une
véritable flambée de l'antisémitisme à
laquelle nous assistons dans notre pays
insulte injure menace de mort tag
dégradation de bâtiment agression
physique tentative d'incendie contre des
portes d'appartements cyber harcèlement
rythme le quotidien de beaucoup trop de
NS compatriotes de confessions juifes
qui se sentent menacés et qui ont peur
cet antisémitisme grandissant désinhibé
dans la France d'aujourd'hui il fait
peur il nous fait peur il nous fait
honte le combattre doit être l'affaire
de tous de tous les républicains pas
seulement l'affaire de nos compatriotes
Juifs c'est notre affaire à nous tous
car cet antisémitisme ce n'est pas la
France c'est la négation de la
République française c'est une attaque
contre notre République et nos valeurs
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous dire à
la représentation nationale à tous les
Français quelles sont les mesures
précises que vous avez mis en place pour
protéger les Français juifs tous les
Juifs en France protéger leur sécurité
et nous dire également quelles sont les
mesures envisagées pour renforcer la
mobilisation notre mobilisation à tous
contre ce poison de
l'antisémitisme
merci beaucoup ma cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald daranin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outremèes
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée constancerip comme l'a dit
madame la Première ministre le président
de la République nous a demandé dès
évidemment les drames ignobles des
attentats terroristes islamistes contre
les populations israéliennes dès le 7
octobre de renforcer considérablement la
sécurité de tous les lieux où les
Français de confession juives vont pour
leur culte vont évidemment mettre leurs
enfants à l'école s'ils le souhaitent ou
dans les lieux culturels ou
communautaires qui fréquentent
assidument c'est donc 950 sites partout
en France sur le territoire national que
nous protégeons grâce aux 10000
policiers gendarmes et militaire de
sentinelle qui permettent en effet de
lutter contre cette peur qui touche
légitimement nos compatriotes de
confession juives et dont la République
est là pour les protéger absolument
complètement et jour et nuit ces actes
antisémite ces actes antisémites madame
la députée malheureusement ne sont pas
une légende 857 actes antisémite depuis
le 7 octobre c'est-à-dire autant d'actes
antisémite que depuis toute l'année
écoulée en 3 semaines grâce à la
position des des policiers des gendarmes
des militas de sentinell présents devant
les lieux communautaires que j'ai évoqué
c'est 425 interpellés et je veux dire
ici la fermeté notamment du ministère de
l'Intérieur pour le retrait de titre
systématique des étrangers qui seraient
parmi ces personnes interpellées et
l'éloignement systématique il y a 27
personnes dans centre de rétention
administratif depuis une semaine du fait
notamment des interpellations fait par
le ministère de de l'intérieur nous
avons également une haine sur sur
Internet 5916 signalements Faros dont
296 personnes ont été identifiées par
les services du ministère de la Justice
et je vrais donner deux exemple ici pour
comprenne qu'il n'y ait pas d'impunité
un individu étranger a été renvoyé dans
son pays le 9 octobre dernier suite à
des crit de mort au Juifs mort à Israël
un individu le 28 octobre sur TikTok qui
a appelé à la haine et à la menace de
mort contre le rabat de Levalois a non
seulement été interpellé mis en garde à
vue et déféré par les services du
ministère de la Justice en prison merci
beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Emmanuel Maquet pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition énergétique madame la
ministre vous nous avez présenté
triomphalement je crois la semaine
dernière une réforme du marché de
l'électricité la position de la France
aurait prévalu sur celle de l'Allemagne
une fois n'est pas coutume il faut donc
s'en réjouir cette victoire c'est
d'abord celle des républicains qui
réclament de longues dates avec
constance et parfois contre les bans de
la majorité que les prix de
l'électricité soient moins dépendant de
ceux du gaz et que le parc nucléaire
historique soit soutenu dans les défis
qui l'attendent
mieux vaut tard que jamais vous
rattrapez les dégâts du premier mandat
présidentiel placé sous l'idéologie
antinucléaire mais les Français ont
appris à se méfier des effets d'annonce
l'hiver dernier leur a montré les
limites du système en cas de hausse des
prix la répercussion sur le pouvoir
d'achat est immédiat en cas de baisse
par contre on doit attendre très
longtemps pour voir les factures
diminuer pour cette pour que cet accord
soit vraiment bénéfique pour les
français pour les artisans pour les
commerçants comme nos boulangers dont la
situation est si difficile et notre
compétitivité industrielle il faut un
engagement clair les contrats
bidirectionnels permettront à l'état de
soutenir EDF lorsque les prix sont bas
et à EDF de reverser à l'état ce surplu
lorsque les prix seront hauts ma
question madame la ministre est donc
très simple dans cette hypothèse de pris
élevé est-ce que ces recettes seront
immédiatement et intégralement reversées
au ménage aux artisans et aux
industriels concrètement est-ce que les
Français bénéficieront des prix bas
qu'ils méritent au regard des
investissements massifs sur le nucléaire
qu'ils ont consentis depuis 50 ans enfin
prévoyez-vous pour nos petites et
moyennes entreprises les boulangers les
restaurateurs les artisans qui sont
exclus des tarifs réglementés alors que
certains de nos pays partenaires
européens protègent leurs PME bravo je
vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier verrand ministre en charge du
renouveau démocratique et porte-parole
du gouvernement merci Madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Emmanuel
Maquet c'est vrai qu'avec le président
de la République nous avions fait une
promesse au français celle de reprendre
le contrôle des prix de l'électricité
celle de reprendre en main l'avenir
énergétique de la France je vous réponds
à la place d'agè perunach parce qu'elle
est elle est absente mais je le fais
avec plaisir et vous nous donnez vous
nous donnez un point positif monsieur le
député et je vais me permettre de le
faire aussi à mon tour c'est vrai que
nous avions en commun cette conviction
que c'est en européen que nous
gagnerions ce combat et n nous opposions
ainsi à l'extrême droite à l'extrême
gauche qui considérait que le marché
européen rendait absolument impossible
cette solution européenne et en faisait
même un argument de plus souverainiste
pour sortir du marché européen et pour
autant la promesse du président de la
République elle a été tenue parce que
nous avons obtenu de nos voisins
allemands et nous avons obtenu de la
Commission européenne cette capacité à
découpler le prix de l'électricité et du
gaz et donc cette capacité à reprendre
effectivement le contrôle des prix de
l'électricité maintenant que cet accord
est en place on se tourne vous le savez
vers l'avenir avec la loi de production
énergétique c'est une loi qui va marquer
une étape clé dans la définition de
notre politique énergétique nationale
elle va nous permettre de nous projeter
dans un mix énergétique décarboné avec
la reconnaissance du nucléaire vous
l'avez dit mais aussi des émissions des
gaz des des énergies renouvelables mais
aussi la sobriété énergétique il sera
aussi question de notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement mais également de la
régulation après 2025 avec l'objectif
partagé là encore monsieur le député
décidément que les français bénéficient
le plus vite possible du prix le plus
proche des coûts de production donc les
mécanismes sont sont en cours de
réflexion et d'élaboration et dans les
prochains jours nous mettrons à la
consultation la stratégie française
énergie climat qui reprendra d'ailleurs
très largement les travaux du député
Armand que je salue ici mais aussi de
l'ensemble des groupes politiques de
notre Parlement qui travaillent depuis
des mois avec les élus locaux et qui
servira de base à la loi de production
énergétique je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre 2 secondes
cet accord fera-t-il baisser oui ou non
la facture des
Français je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Pierre Darville pour le
groupe
GDR madame la ministre ce dimanche sur
le marché de port debouc des artistes
s'étaient donné rendez-vous afin de
produire une œuvre collective pour la
paix à destination de l'ONU l'aspiration
à la paix est forte dans notre peuple et
parmi les peuples du monde et il est
salut l terire que cette aspiration
matinée d'inquiétude et de révolte
puisse se manifester dans un moment où
l'humanité est traversée par les
conflits nous n'oublions pas l'Ukraine
ou l'Arménie la désolation les bombes la
fuite les
morts les attaques criminelles
meurtrières et aveugles du Hamas ont
alimenté un engrenage de guerre et de
violence qui semble sans limite
l'offensive militaire qui s'intensifie à
Gaza est insupportable tous les crimes
de guerre doivent être condamnés les
Nations Unies décrivent une situation où
une population entière est déshumanisée
cela ressemble à une vengeance aveugle à
une terrible punition collective et le
risque d'un embrasement n'est pas écarté
bien sûr il faut une trêve humanitaire
d'urgence et la libération des otages
mais en toile de fond il y a ce conflit
qui dure depuis des décennies et qui ne
se règlera pas ainsi il y a la
persistance de l'occupation et du blocus
le développement de la colonisation qui
prive une part de l'hum
de ses droits élémentaires dans le
fracas et le drame ces événements
viennent nous rappeler à quel point nos
organisations internationales ont été
affaiblis à force d'être contourné à
quel point le droit international est
fragilisé à force d'être bafoué les
nationalismes et les intégrismes se
nourrissent du conflit installent une
polarisation mortifère qui ferme les
issues alimente les haines or il ne peut
y avoir de paix durable que dans la
justice et le respect du droit des
peuples il y a des interlocuteurs
possibles je pense à Marouan bargouti
parce que nous n'avons rien d'autre en
tête que le sort de ces femmes et de ces
hommes d'Israël et de Palestine nous
souhaitons que la France par le haut
cessz le
feu je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame la Ministre Laurence bon ministre
chargé de
l'Europe mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député Pierre
d'ville je vais vous faire une réponse
en deux temps la la première en ce qui
concerne les crimes de guerre que vous
avez mentionné et la deuxième sur les
perspectives politiques et des deux
états le 7 octobre dernier des milliers
de terroristes du Hamas épaulés par
d'autres groupes terroristes dont le
Djihad islamique et la branche armée du
FPLP ont abattu en Israël plus de 1400
personnes et vous avez vu comme moi les
images vous avez vu comme moi la
sauvagerie la barbarie les giif tué
assassiné les femmes et les bébés
mutilés les corps sans vie profané parce
que juif comme l'a dit le président de
la République cette barbarie qui s'est
abattu sur Israël est aussi une
catastrophe pour les Palestiniens que
nous n'associons en aucune manière au
Hamas qui dirige Gaza avec la
terreur le terrorisme est un fléo pour
le Moyen-Orient il est aussi pour nous
il faut rappeler que 35 de nos
compatriotes ont été sauvagement
assassinés par le hin
et que ce groupe terroriste détient en
otage certainement plusieurs autres de
nos compatriotes dont nous sommes
toujours sans nouvelle donc nous le
disons Israël doit pouvoir se défendre
et ce droit doit se faire dans le cadre
du droit international qui doit être
respecté toujours la France a été au
côté du droit elle est
aujourd'hui maintenant au-delà de
l'urgence humanitaire c'est le deuxième
temps de ma réponse il faut mieux
répondre aux aspirations légitimes des
Palestiniens les Palestiniens veulent
vivre dans la dignité loin des atrocités
des terroristes du Hamas il va pouvoir
vivre en paix avec les Israéliens et non
pas face à face mais côte à côte c'est
effectivement de notre responsabilité
collective de redessiner un horizon
politique et même de répondre à cette
aspiration la position de la France est
constante et nous la réaffirmons
aujourd'hui avec force il faut de la
sécurité pour Israël et un état pour les
palestinien ces deux éléments forment un
tout indissociable madame colonel a sans
ambigé lors du sommet de la paix je vous
mercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame
Marie-Pierre rixin pour le groupe
Renaissance ma question merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la Première ministre madame la
Première ministre depuis le 24 juin 2022
l'avortement n'est plus un droit fédéral
aux États-Unis l'atteinte à ce droit
fondamental fragile sur le plan
juridique dans l'une des plus grandes
démocraties du monde confirme la
réversibilité des droits des femmes et
l'impérieuse nécessité de garantir
constitutionnellement le droit à l'IVG
face aux assauts de force
réactionnaire c'est pourquoi dès le 30
juin 2022 la majorité présidentielle
déposa une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle visant à garantir le
droit à d'IVG et que par la suite
députés puis sénateurs dans une démarche
transpartisane ont adopté tour à tour
deux textes constitutionnels allant dans
ce sens aujourd'hui avec la mobilisation
tion de nombreux parlementaires et des
associations féministes le président de
la République a annoncé déposer au
Conseil d'État un projet de loi
constitutionnel il ouvre ainsi la voix à
un processus de réforme
constitutionnelle inédit dans le monde
afin de garantir pleinement la liberté
des femmes à pouvoir recourir à l'IVG en
France la vulnérabilité des droits des
femmes est une réalité implacable
l'intérêt de la constitutionnalisation
de ce droit est donc double à la fois
lui conférer une plus grande sécurité
juridique et le rendre irréversible pour
les générations futures et d'autre part
manifester avec force l'attachement de
la France à ce droit fondamental des
femmes à travers cette décision
pionnière le président de la République
rappelle combien ce droit loin d'être
seulement un sujet de femme est au cœur
de notre vie démocratique ici en France
pays des Lumières pays des droits de
l'homme et assurément des droits des
femmes madame la Première ministre quand
le droit à sera-t-il pérénisé en France
et inscrit dans notre
Constitution merci beaucoup ma cher
collègue la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Marie-Pierre xxin il y a une
chose que toutes les femmes ne savent
que trop bien leurs droits sont fragiles
et Simone de beauauvoir disait vrai en
affirmant qu'il seraiit toujours les
premiers remis en question
au cœur de ces droits il y a celui de
disposer de son corps il y a la garantie
de pouvoir librement recourir à
l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse ce droit est le fruit d'une
lutte du Manifeste des 343 du procès de
bobini ce droit est le fruit du courage
celui de Simon veille à la tribune de
cette
assemblée
si ce droit est aujourd'hui défendu sur
la quasi-ttalité des bans de cet
hémicycle nous avons un devoir de
vigilance vous l'avez rappelé la
décision de la Cour suprême des
États-Unis l'année dernière à rappelé
que le droit à l'avortement pouvait être
menacé même dans une grande démocratie
et jusque sur notre continent plusieurs
partis d'extrême droite veulent remettre
en cause cette liberté fondamentale pour
les
femmes
ce devoir de vigilance vous le partagez
c'est le sens de la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle adoptée à une très
large majorité sur ces bancs et voté
ensuite par le Sénat ce devoir de
vigilance nous le partageons le 8 mars
dernier en rendant l'hommage de la
Nation à Giselle Alimi le président de
la République s'est engagé à inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans le marbre de la
Constitution et dimanche dernier après
concertation avec les groupes
parlementaires le président de la
République a annoncé qu'un projet de loi
constitutionnel serait transmis dès
cette semaine au Conseil d'État et
présenté au Conseil des ministres avant
la fin de l'année ce texte permettra de
consacrer plus encore la liberté des
femmes à recourir à l'IVG en
l'inscrivant dans la Constitution
mesdames et messieurs les députés
certains affirment qu'il n'y a pas
urgence pour le droit des femmes je
crois au contraire qu'il y a toujours
urgence à se battre toujours urgence àve
au liberté des femmes c'est ma
conviction c'est la conviction de mon
gouvernement et c'est c'est la
vôtre et c'est une conviction qui
rassemble largement sur ces bans c'est
pourquoi pour toutes les femmes avec le
président de la République nous
souhaitons que ce ce droit soit inscrit
dans la Constitution en 2024 je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
JP
insoumise madame la Première ministre la
directrice exécutive de l'UNICEF a
affirmé lundi devant le Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU plus de 420 enfants
sont tués ou blessés chaque jour à Gaza
Jean-François Corti vice-président de
Médecin du Monde explique dans
Libération on est passé d'une prison à
ciel ouvert à un charnier à ciel ouvert
madame la Première ministre vous et
votre gouvernement avez fait le choix de
soutenir
inconditionnellement le gouvernement de
Monsieur netanah dans une démocratie
c'est le droit pour d'autres et ils sont
nombreux de penser de dire que le
carnage doit s'arrêter tout de suite
qu'il faut in cesser le feu immédiat
dans le monde entier notamment en Europe
comme à Londres très récemment des
manifestations très puissantes ont lieu
en France ces manifestations sont
interdites comme cela a été le cas
samedi dernier à Paris madame la
Première ministre pourquoi pourquoi
cette position intenable et
incompréhensible
réalité un climat dangereux est en train
de sinstaller dangereux pour le pays la
démocratie et l'ensemble des libertés
publi rassemblement national et dans
votre majorité certains ont cru bon de
s'en prendre à la liberté de la presse
de cibler la FP et de se prononcer pour
que lui soit retiré ses subventions
publiques un autre député de votre
majorité rajoutant menace réelle don ce
dernier est l'objet déclare à la radio
jeanluc Mélenchon est un danger pour la
société il devrait être
fich la première ministre vous
désolidarisez-vous nettement de ces
propos irresponsables la première
victime d'une guerre est la vérité c'est
vrai à chaque fois ça l' est
particulièrement à Gaza pilonné réduite
au silence à ce jour 28 journalistes y
ont été tués deux tribunes viennent
d'être publié demandant aux autorités
françaises d'appeler à la protection des
journalistes qui tentent actuellement de
travailler dans l'enclave pour y faire
leur métier informé reprenez-vous cet
appel à votre compte autant de questions
relié à cette
je vous
remercie la
par Monsieur Habib s'il vous plaît vous
n'avez pas la parole la parole est à
Madame Laurence bon ministre des
affaires
européennes merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le député Jérôme mesdames
etessieurs les députés je vais peut-être
PE mais d'abord Israël dans sa réponse
légitime à l'attaque terroriste dont
elle a été victime doit aussi protéger
les populations civiles en application
du droit humanitaire car ces populations
civiles n'ont pas payer les prix des
crimes commis par des groupes
terroristes qui ne les représentent
pas il faut être clair je crois que le
gouvernement l'a
été les terroristes du Hamas ne
représentent pas le peuple palestinien
la cause palestinenne il faut le dire
encore plus dans le contexte actuel de
grande volatilité où certains acteurs
tentent d'installer de la confusion le
rejet le plus ferme des actions du Hamas
est le moyen le plus sûr de faire
entendre la voix des Palestiniens et la
France condamne les agissements du Hamas
et elle soutient les droits des
Palestiniens peut-être puis-je aussi
rappeler que face à la crise humanitaire
qu'endure la population civile une
population civile qui souffre Gaza
puisque vous l'avez évoqué la France a
annoncé 20 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui passeront par les
agences des Nations Unies le CICR et les
ONG et elle est prête à accroître cet
effort si
nécessaire et cette aide aux population
et aux déplacés elle a demandé
l'ouverture des corridors et la pose
humanitaire pour la leur faire parvenir
d'urgence à nouveau je le dis la
distribution de l'aide aux populations
civile à commencé par les vulnérables
suppose une trêve humanitire qui pourra
amener à insisser le feu et les
personnes qui souhaitent pouvoir sortir
de Gaza doivent pouvoir le faire sans en
être empêché nous l'avons demandé pour
nos agents nos ressortissants leurs
famille et enfin il faudra une solution
politique pour que les deux peuples puis
viv côte à côte je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre je vous
remercie la parole est à madame Béatrice
sur PHPP Bard pour le rassemblement
national merci Madame la la présidente
ma question s'adresse à Madame Rima
abdoumak ministre de la Culture 3
semaines après le début de la guerre
entre Israël et le mouvement palestinien
hamass Gaza est coupé du monde cette
phrase est extraite d'une dépêche AFP du
27 octobre on y liit bien la guerre
contre le mouvement palestinien àas
bravo en fait cette dépêche n'est que le
reflet des consignes donné par la
direction de l'agence dans une note
interne on y lit notamment que pour
décrire le Hamas il faut parler je cite
de combattant du Hamas et non
d'islamiste du Hamas tandis que le
qualificatif terroriste est tout
simplement à proscrire le directeur de
l'information expliquant que ce mot a
tout bonnement perdu son sens pourtant
il n'y a pas si longtemps laafp
employait ce mot de terror
pour décrire les exactions de daesh
d'alqaïda les assassinats de Boko Haram
l'attentat contre Charlie Hebdo mais que
s'est-il passé depuis décapiter des
bébés éventrer des femmes enceintes
brûler des êtres humains kidnappé violé
ce n'est pas du terrorisme et bien non
apparemment pour lafp lafp est l'une des
trois grandes agences mondiales la seule
européenne ses abonnés sont les médias
français mais aussi étrangers les
entreprises les institutions son pouvoir
d'influence est donc énorme considérable
j'ai été journaliste près de 40 ans
pendant de longues années la FP c'était
la Bible de l'information mais ce
temps-là est révolu alors madame la
ministre l'état s'apprête à verser 141
millions d'euros à la FP budget en
hausse de 5 % au titre écoutez bien de
sa mission d'intérêt général alors
madame la ministre comment comptez-vous
réagir quand sur le site de votre
ministère il est écrit que la FP et la
seule agence mondiale qui produise de
l'information originale complète
objective et digne de
confiance je vous
remci la parole est à Madame Rima Abdou
malac ministre de la
Culture madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Ballard un premier appel pour
paraphraser ce que disait ma collègue
Laurence boun la France a très
clairement défini le Hamas comme un
groupe terroriste ainsi que l'Union
européenne et un très grand nombre de
pays autre rappel important si le
ministerère de la culture fin mon je
vais être obligé de vous rappeler à
[Applaudissements]
l'ordre si le ministère la culture
finance en partie lafp lafp n'est pas
une agence gouvernementale c'est une
agence de presse indépendante et à
l'instar des agences Reuters ou
Associated Press lafp a expliqué que
depuis plus de 20 ans ils ont pris cette
consigne de ne pas utiliser le mot
terrorisme pour s'en tenir au faits mais
il me semble que les faits décrits dans
le cas des attaques barbares du Hamas
sont suffisamment claires pour que tout
le monde comprenne qu'il s'agit d'actes
terroristes les médias qui rédigent des
articles à partir des dépêches de lafp
utilise d'ailleurs très souvent s'il
vous plaît on écouteot
terrorist dans le contexte de dans le
contexte de gravité est-ce que vous
pouvez m'écouter jusqu'au bout'il vous
plaît dans le contexte de gravité que
nous vivons et je le dis avec d'autant
plus d'émotion en présence de famille
d'otage
retenu s'il vous plaît depuis le 7
octobre où le Hamas a franchi toutes les
lignes rouges imaginables avec cette
barbarie et cette cruauté
inqualifiable je peux comprendre que le
choix de ne pas utiliser ce mot de
terrorise pu susciter des remous des
incompréhensions des indignations mais
monsieur le député Ballard le
gouvernement n'écrit pas les dépêches de
lafp et ne corrige pas les dépêches de
laafp la presse est indépendante dans
notre pays monsieur le député
Balard ce qui m'a choqué pour ma part
puisque vous me demandez mon avis c'est
la mention de l'exemple de Nelson
Mandela dans un des communiqués
d'explication de laafp je pense qu'on ne
peut pas laisser penser merci qu'on met
sur le même plan le Hamas et Nelson
Mandela et j'aurais aimé que l' fait
mesure cette responsabilité toute
particulière merci beaucoup madame la
ministre
bon allez s'il vous plaît un peu de
calme on essaie d'écouter les différents
orateurs et la parole est à madame
Béatrice bamie pour le groupe
horizon merci Madame la présidente ma
question s'adresse à Madame la Ministre
des Sports des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques madame la
ministre l'attaque du quart de
l'Olympique Lyonnais ce dimanche soir
est le symbole d'un profond abétissement
et c'est un exemple désastreux pour la
jeunesse mais c'est plus que cela c'est
une insulte lancée à la face des
sportifs de tous ceux qui pratique qui
aime et qui encadre le sport en France
c'est aussi pour eux pour ces millions
de Français que je vous adresse cette
question car le sport c'est avant tout
de très belles histoires des valeurs du
lien social de l'émancipation le
dépassement de soi et le respect des
règles tous les jours et sur tous les
terrains les 180000 clubs qui maillent
notre territoire permettent d'élever les
corps et les esprits d'offrir un cadre
et des certitudes nous sommes nombreux à
être convaincus que le sport porte une
partie des remèdes au mots que connaît
notre société et notre jeunesse en
particulier
je salue les milliers d'animateurs
d'éducateurs et d'entraîneurs qui uvrent
sur tous les territoires de la
République nous leur sommes
reconnaissant pour le travail social
qu'ils accomplissent la pratique du
sport sera la grande cause nationale
pour
2024 dans cet esprit le président de la
République a annoncé une nouvelle
impulsion en faveur de l'inclusion par
le sport notamment par la création d'une
alliance pour copiloter cette politique
publique essentielle un acte fondateur a
d'ors et déjà été posé ce comité de
l'Alliance a été confirmé au cours du
récent comité interministériel des
villes madame la ministre pouvez-vous
nous réaffirmer l'engagement du du
gouvernement à faire du sport un pilier
majeur du pacte républicain pouvez-vous
nous préciser les éléments concrets
soutenant l'inclusion sur nos
territoires et dans les clubs sportifs
je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole est à
Madame Amélie ministre sport des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Béatrice béami
vous mentionnez l'attaque AB dont on
fait l'objet à Marseille les bus de
l'Olympique Lyonnais et je ne veux pas
oublier les gestes antisémites les cris
racistes et les champs homophobes qui
ont été par ailleurs à déplorer en
tribune dimanche soir je veux le redire
avec la fermeté que ces comportements
appellent jamais nous ne cèderons face à
ceux qui cassent détruisent ou salissent
le sport les auteurs de ses faits seront
retrouvés poursuivis et condamnés avec
des sanctions que je souhaite les plus
sévères possibles leurs agissements sont
la négation même du sport et de ses
valeurs vous l'avez dit le sport a autre
chose à apporter en particulier à notre
jeunesse parfois en perte de repèr pour
elle le sport a le pouvoir de redonner
un cadre et du sens c'est la raison pour
laquelle sous l'impulsion du Président
de la République et de la première
ministre mon ministère porte en effet
une ambition et des moyens inédits pour
l'inclusion par le sport avec un nouvel
investissement de 300 millions d'euros
au côté des collectivités dans les
équipements sportifs notamment en qpv
avec un réseau constitué de 10000 clubs
sportifs engagés à travers les
territoires partout en France avec le
recrutement de 1000 éducateurs
sociosportifs la mobilisation de 50
millions d'euros pour ces missions
d'animation d'intervention et de
médiation ces mesures elles seront
suivies animées par une nouvelle
alliance pour l'inclusion par le sport
transpartisan composé d'élus de
servicees de l'état de représentants de
la société civile et d'acteurs
associatifs dont l'action nous permettra
d'augmenter de 20 à 100000 le nombre de
bénéficiaires des actions d'insertion
par le sport en capitalisant sur les
dispositifs mis en place depuis 2017
cette alliance elle va nous permettre
aussi de piloter l'été olympique et
paralympique que nous préparons avec les
clubs sportifs et avec les ministres de
l'Éducation nationale de la culture et
de la ville pour que l'élan des jeux
bénéficie aussi à la jeunesse des
quartiers populaires à l'été 24 et que
le sport oui contribue à cimenter le
pacte républicain merci beaucoup madame
la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Gérard
leol pour le groupe socialiste merci
madame la présidente madame la
Présidente cher collègue madame la
Première ministre votre gouvernement
dont la plupart des membres sont
atteints d'une telle immodestie qu'il
déclare à longueur de discours qu'aucun
gouvernement n'a jamais fait mieux
devrait au moins respecter ses
engagements en effet le temps semble
loin où vous vous engagiez madame la
Première ministre où vous promettiez de
gouverner autrement dans le dialogue et
la coconstruction dans nos débats
parfois vifs parfois houleux parfois
consensuel de nombreux amendements ont
été adoptés pour corriger améliorer vos
projets de budget que vous menacez
régulièrement par le 493 c'est notamment
le cas d'un amendement important pour
améliorer les dispositifs
d'accompagnement social des afeu c'est
aussi le cas de plusieurs amendements de
rallonge budget relatif à l'insertion
par l'activité économique ou encore à
l'expérimentation territoire zéro
chômeur de longue durée créé en 2016 et
mise en œuvre dès 2017 c'est une belle
réussite nous le découvrons dans nos
territoires comme à l'entreprise à but
d'emploi la source à Port Jérôme sursène
hélas le projet de loi de finance pour
2024 ne prévoyait que 69 millions
d'euros contraignant l'association à
renoncer aux 25 nouvelles
expérimentations prévues en 2024 4
actuellement 58 territoires l'ont mis en
place et plus de 5000 personnes ont
retrouvé du travail grâce à cette
association cette expérimentation est
même saluée à Bruxelles qui souhaite
mobiliser le Fond Européen d'innovation
sociale lors de la séance dernière des
questions gouvernement le ministre du
travail avait été interrogé sur ce sujet
avait répondu par de trop nombreuses
contevérités c'est pourquoi hier soir
une réaction collective de nombreux
parlementaires de plusieurs groupes
politiques a permis en commission des
finan de voter deux amendements l'un à
31 millions d'euros l'autre à 20
millions d'euros supplémentaires écoute
action résultat résumiez-vous en juillet
2022 allez-vous enfin écouter le
Parlement et retenir ses propositions
bra merci beaucoup mon cher collègu la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier dusopt
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député le seul vous
citez l'expérimentation territoire zé
chemur de longue durée comme vous l'avez
dit elle a été mise en place par une loi
2016 avec 10 territoires et le
gouvernement succè suivant avait porté
cette expérimentation à 60 territoires
nous sommes à 58 aujourd'hui vous dites
le gouvernement tient pas ses
engagements en 2017 c'était 15 millions
d'euros qui étaient budgetés dans le
budget de l'État dont 5 ont été
consommés en 2023 cette année ce sont 44
44,9 million d'euros qui ont été
inscrits et nous finançons effectivement
des expérimentations dans à date 58
territoires qui ont été labelis après
que le comité de sélection les ait agréé
et que j'ai signé les arrêtés d'agrément
nous avons inscrit dans le budget 2024
69 millions d'euros une augmentation de
53 %. vous conviendrez monsieur le
député que passer de 15 millions à 69
millions d'euros en l'espace de 6 ans
n'est pas tout à fait commun pour une
expérimentation où en sommes-nous
aujourd'hui nous en sommes à une
situation où il y a 58 territoires
agréés et l'association nous a fait
savoir que de nouveaux territoires
pourrai être proposés j'ai dit à cette
association par l'intermédèire de mes
équipes bien év évidemment que nous
sommes prêts à présenter des décrets au
Conseil d'État puisque c'est ce que la
loi prévoit pour agréer jusqu'à 25
territoires supplémentaires j'ai dit à
cette association qu'au cours des
dernières années le taux moyen de
sous-consommation de sous-consommation
des budgets était supérieur à 30 %. j'ai
aussi dit à cette association que nous
pouvons nous engager au cours de
l'exercice 2024 à ce que 10 millions
d'euros soi apportés si nécessaire si la
totalité des crédits étit consommé à
condition que les projections de
création d'emploi soient partagées ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui je
rencontre Monsieur Gallois le président
du fond jeudi nous aurons l'occasion de
continuer à discuter mais soyez à même
d'entendre que lorsqu'on passe entre
2023 et 2024 d'un peu moins de 45
millions à 69 millions d'euros ce n'est
pas une baisse de budget et le
gouvernement est au
rendez-vous merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Danielle
auonau pour le groupe la France
insoumiseci madame la
Présidente lundi dernier interrogé sur
l'annonce du syndicat mixte de gestion
de l'eau et de l'assaainissement de
Guadeloupe qui déconseillait à la
population de consommer l'eau du robinet
le ministre Vigier a répondu voyez vous
avez la chance d'avoir un ministre qui
est également biologiste qui va vous
donner les bons conseils et bien vous
faites couler l'eau vous la faites
chauffer et après vous la mettez au
frigo mais bien sûr pourquoi les
Guadeloupéens et guadeloupéennes n'y
avaient pas pensé avant peut-être parce
qu'il et elles savent que le problème
est structurel et ne se réglera pas par
des bons conseils de biologistes tout
ministre qu'il soit en Guadeloupe comme
dans plusieurs autres département
d'idoutrem depuis des années de nombreux
dysfonctionnements dans la gestion des
usines de production d'eau potable du
réseau de distribution et de la gestion
des eaux usées entraîne une situation
catastrophique un/4 de la population de
Guadeloupe n'a pas accès tous les jours
à l'eau du fait des coupures 31 % de la
population maoraaise n'a pas accès à
l'eau courante dans son logement entre
15 et 20 % de la population de guyan n'a
pas accès à l'eau alors que cette région
dispose de la troème réserve d'eau du
monde un habitant et une habitante sur
deux de la réunion ne peut pas pas boire
de l'eau du robinet car impropre à la
consommation mais tout cela vous le
savez car depuis des années habitants
habitantes et élus de ces territoire et
de la nation tout entière alerte sur
cette situation le 2 juin 2023 un
rapport du Comité de l'ONU sur les
droits de l'enfant a même demandé à
l'état français de garantir les droits à
l'eau et à l'assaainissement en outreem
et singulièrement en Guadeloupe à ce
jour en plus d'être condescendante les
réponses de votre gouvernement sont
dramatiquement insuffisantes
heureusement la représentation nationale
s saisi du problème mardi dernier en
commission des finances la proposition
de notre groupe d'un plan d'urgence de
100 millions d'euros sur le budget 2024
pour rendre effectif le droit d'accès à
l'eau dans les outrmers a été voté
madame la Première ministre
conserverez-vous ce financement ainsi
que tous ceux adoptés en commission en
faveur des outremèes après le Funest 43
que vous prévoyez sur la deème partie du
budget je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur philippe Bet ministre en charge
des outr mes merci madame la Présidente
m messieur les députés madame auonau
mépris madame bonau lorsque la semaine
dernière 24 he après l'ouragon Timi Tami
je suis allé sur place à la rencontre
des populations qui avait été pour
certains dévasté vous le savez et qui
pour et qui pour d' ont perdu leur outil
de travail et il nécessitait que l'on
soit à côté d'eux et j'étais à côé
où est mépris où est mépris madame AUAU
lorsque Gérald le ministre de
l'Intérieur a décidé d'enclencher la
reconnaissance de catastrophe naturelle
justement suite au passage de cette
agant ami à la Guadeloupe où il mépris
madameonau lorsque comme beaucoup de
guadeloupéen et guadeloupéenne j'ai
constaté j'ai constaté que l'eau était
de couleur marron lorsqu'il y a des
grandes inondations et pourquoi madame
auonau et pourquoi madame pour raison
simple c'est que les les usines de
traitement d'eau ne marchent quasiment
plus et Madame auonau ù mépris puisque
vous venez parler vous venez de parler à
l'instant des investissements financiers
ou il mépris lorsque nous signons la
semaine dernière pour 320 millions
d'euros avec la région je remercie le
président haralus avec le département je
remercie le président Losbar de manière
à ce que l'on puisse enfin régler ses
problèmes où est méprise de ce
gouvernement pour l'au je repars ce soir
à maotte je devais y aller avec Géral
armmanin qui doit rester sur le
territoire hexagonal parce que nous
avons lancé un plan de 400 millions
d'euros donc nous sommes pas dans le méb
nous sommes dans la considération et
nous sommes dans la considération pour
les femmes et les hommes des territoires
ultramarins qui méritent enfin qui
mérite enfin que ces problèmes d'eau les
prennent à bras le corps et croyez-le
bien madame obonau venez avec moi ce
soir et vous verrez que sur place nous
jissons et vous verrez que sur place
nous avançons et vous verrez que sur
place et nous faisons des progrès chaque
jour je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame merana
Reed arbelo pour le groupe
GDR madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
yaurana ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre des Armées le 21 janvier
2021 le traité sur l'interdiction des
armes nucléaires est entré en vigueur
il comporte des dispositions
humanitaires ayant tré à l'assistance
aux victimes et à la remise en état de
l'environnement la France se refuse à le
ratifier or le 27 octobre 2023 Kiribati
et le Kazakhstan ont présenté une
résolution inédite aux nations- Unies
celle-ci concerne le lourd héritage des
armes nucléaires mettant l'accent à la
fois sur les dommages physiques et
moraux aux victimes mais également sur
la remise en état de l'environnement
dans les états à touché par l'emploi ou
la mise à l'esser des armes nucléaires
171 États ont voté pour ce texte les
quatre puissances nucléaires ont voté
contre dans la France dès le dépôt du
projet de résolution des associations
telles que Acan France ont dénoncé
l'attitude de rejet de la France perçu
comme un affran envers toutes les
victimes de ces essais y compris ses
propres
enfants le même jour en réponse à une
affaire concernant le stockage en couche
ologique profonde des déchets
radioactifs le Conseil constitutionnel a
rendu une décision inédite en estimant
que le législateur lorsqu'il adopte des
mesures susceptibles de porter une
atteinte grave et durable à
l'environnement doit veiller à ce que
les choix destinés à répondre aux
besoins du présent ne compromettent pas
la capacité des générations futures et
des autres peuples à satisfaire leurs
propres
besoins les juges de la juridiction
suprême ont donc eux saisi les dangers
du stockage des déchets nucléaires et
leurs effets nocifs sur l'environnement
et la santé humaine en Polynésie les
déchets nucléaires sont enfoui dans deux
puits d'un km de profondeur dans une
zone géologiquement instable car
fragilisé par l'explosion de plus de 140
essai nucléaires souterrain et menaçant
de s'effondrer à tout moment le
ministère se félicite du suivi
géomécanique et radiologique de la tole
de mourourois avec le dispositif tels 2
merci ma chère collègue merci parole est
à Madame Patricia mirales ministre en
charge des anciens combattants et de la
mémoire madame la présidente madame la
députée Mariana Reid
aberlot permettez-moi d'abord d'excuser
le ministre des Armées Sébastien Lecornu
qui est occupé avec l'actualité
internationale complexe que vous
connaissez peut-être je vais commencer
ma réponse en vous disant que nous
n'avons pas attendu un traité pour
travailler nous avons avec le le
président de la République ouvert les
archives sur la Polynésie et donc il y a
600 archives qui ont été ouvertes et qui
permettent aux historiens aux
enseignants et aux chercheurs de pouvoir
se rendre compte de ce qui a été fait
avant sur les essais nucléaires nous
sommes évidemment héritiers de de cette
histoire et nous en faisons toute la
lumière nous en faisons toute la lumière
peut-être vous dire aussi que le
ministère des armées est conscient de
ses responsabilités particulier sur ce
sujet des essais nucléaires en Polynésie
il porte l'exigence de la transparence
vouue par le Président de la République
la surveillance des atols continue à
être réalisée selon un plan rigoureux et
complet le ministère des des armées a
effectué une rénovation du système de
télésurveillance du site que vous
connaissez appelé tel site la dernière
publication de 2022 confirme que les
objectifs de surveillance ont été
remplis tant en terme d'alerte que du
suivi de l'évolution
géoécanique les mouvements de la
couronne corélienne sont devenus très
faibles et le détachement d'un fragment
important créant une vague est devenu
très improbable nous continuons
naturellement la surveillance les
mesures effectuées permettent de classer
le niveau d'évolution au niveau zéro de
l'échelle des risques et à fagatova les
les campagnes d'observation périodique
mené depuis 2001 confirme également la
stabilité des atols le prochain le mois
prochain comme chaque année une comm
information rendra compte des résultats
de la surveillance je vous rappelle les
résultats de l'année dernière donc en
2022 du point de vue radiologique on ne
mesure dans l'eau les végétaux et les
poissons que des traces de réactivité à
très faible niveau identique à celle des
années précédentes merci beaucoup madame
la ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Michel lozana pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma questionade monsieur Aurélien
Rousseau ministre de la santé et de la
prévention en ce 31 octobre je tiens à
saluer les associations et bénévoles
partout en France qui ont organisé des
opérations dans le cadre du mouvement
octobre rose
Ce ce mouvement est né et vit grâce à
leur engagement je tiens également à
vous remercier madame la Présidente
d'avoir illuminé la façade de
l'Assemblée nationale aux couleurs
d'Octobre Rose l'ensemble de des actions
nous permet de véhiculer deux messages
essentiels d'abord apporter notre
soutien aux femmes et aux hommes touchés
par un cancer ainsi qu'à leurs proches
aussi sensibiliser la population à
l'importance du dépistage détecter tôt
un cancer du sein se soigne dans 90 %
des cas la démarche est simple dè 25 ans
il est préconisé de procéder
régulièrement à un examen clinique ainsi
qu'à des autopalpations entre 50 à 74
ans tous les 2 ans un dépistage gratuit
recommandé pourtant en 2022 seulement 47
% des femmes éligibles à ce dépistage yy
on participé c'est insuffisant et en
baisse depuis la crise sanitaire c'est
pourquoi je salue monsieur le ministre
votre volonté d'aller vers les personnes
les plus éloignées notamment à travers
le rendez-vous préventif à trois âges
clés votés par le Parlement en 2023 et
adapté au sein du PLFSS en
2024 cependant nous devons aller plus
loin la stratégie décennale de lutte
contre les cancers vise à réaliser 1
million de dépistages supplémentaires
entre 2021 et 2025 cela inclut aussi
celui du cancer du sein qui demeure la
première cause de décès par cancer chez
les femmes aussi Monsieur le Ministre
pouvez-vous nous exposer votre stratégie
afin d'atteindre les objectifs fixés par
cette stratégie décennal et d'améliorer
le taux de participation au dépistage du
cancer du sein je vous remercie merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau ministre de
la santé et de la prévention madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député euh merci
beaucoup de cette question et en effet
la santé des femmes était un des axes
prioritaires de cette partie 3 du du
PLFSS que nous avons examiné hier et
même si elle est moins prestigieuse que
la façade du Palais Bourbon le celle du
ministère la santé est également habillé
de rose pourquoi pour dire la nécessité
de la mobilisation absolue sur le
dépistage vous avez dit les chiffres 47
% des femmes passent par le dépistage
organisé 10 % à peu près font
d'elles-même ce mouvement vers le
dépistage nous devons aller plus loin
parce que nous avons reculé durant la
crise sanitaire et le cancer du sein
c'est une femme sur 8 dans sa vie qui va
y être exposée et c'est aujourd'hui
encore 12000 morts
chaque année en France 12000 morts dont
une bonne partie s'ils étaient dépistés
plutôt serait évitable donc vous
m'interrogez sur la stratégie que nous
mettons en œuvre la première monsieur le
député c'est de modifier notre manière
de mettre en place ce dépistage organisé
les centres régionaux de dépistage du
cancer vont être profondément remaniés
avec des opérations d'allé vert qui
seront conduit par l'assurance maladie
et les ARS en prenant en prenant appui
sur tout ce que nous avons fait pendant
la crise sanitaire et par ailleurs les
crcdc dans leur dimension
épidémiologique orienteront ces
recherches nous espérons bien atteindre
1 million effectivement de dépistage de
plus par an 2uxème élément une
mobilisation pour rénover le parc de
mammographe de 100 millions trè élément
qui est très important c'est les
dotations en recherche et en innovation
notamment ce qu'on peut aujourd'hui voir
en terme d'interception du cancer c'est
un progrès immense et nous devons tous
nous en saisir mais la première étape
c'est le dépistage vous avez raison
merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Michel
Guignot pour le rassemblement
national merci merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur le ministre selon la mission
immigration asile et intégration
l'accueil et l'hébergement des migrants
dans la diversité de leur situation sont
à la charge de votre ministère c'est
d'ailleurs principalement à cette fin
que vous avez versé en 2022 plus de 980
millions d'euros de subventions aux
associations ce chiffre qui a scandalisé
de nombreux Français et pourtant
largement sous-estimé en effet comme
l'indique en détail le jaune budgétaire
sur l'effort financier de l'État en
faveur des associations de très
nombreuses subventions ont été versé par
la dial la Délégation interministérielle
pour l'hébergement et l'aide au logement
pour information les crédits de la dial
de la dial pardon qui depuis 2019
augmente chaque année de 10 % en moyenne
sont affectés sur le budget du ministère
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires dans le
programme 170 7 ou plutôt devrais-je
dire le potoros 177 le budget discret
pour l'immigration en effet sur la seule
année 2022 la dial a versé près d'un
milliard 8 d'euros de subvention pour
les demandeurs d'asile c'est donc
environ 60 % d'un budget créé
initialement pour aider les personnes
sans abri ou mal logé je rappelle 624
morts en 2022 depuis 2019 la dial a
verser 6 milliards d'euros de subvention
pour l'accueil et l'hébergement des
demandeurs d'asile dont les 2 tiers
d'ailleurs ne devrai pas être dans notre
pays la ma question est donc simple
monsieur le ministre une partie du
budget du ministère de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoire finance-t-elle discrètement
par milliard une une immigration dont 61
% des Français ne veulent pas et contre
laquelle vous affirmez vouloir lutter je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Sabrina Agresti
roubage ministre en charge de la
citoyenneté de la ville merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Michel
Guignot écoutez vous nous interrogez sur
les financements accordés par le
ministère en fait de
l'Intérieur et des outremèes aux
associations au titre de la politique
d'immigration comme j'ai eu l'occasion
de le rappeler en commission des lois
lors de l'examen des crédits de la
mission immigration asile et intégration
l'état encadre scrupuleusement les
missions et les fonds qu'il délègue aux
associations qui compte pour près de la
moitié des crédits de la mission ce sont
ces associations qui assurent pour le
compte de l'État l'hébergement des
demandeurs d'asile et à ce titre
accompagne ces personnes dans leur
démarche où accompagne les réfugés les
réfugiés vers l'emploi comme le
programme d'accompagnement global pour
l'intégration des réfugiés le programme
agir ces associations sont effectivement
des opérateurs de l'État et participent
activement à l'intégration des étrangers
en France Monsieur le Député ces
associations sont dans leur rôle en
fournissant un accompagnement
administratif et juridique aux étrangers
qui souhaitent utiliser les voies de
recours juridictionnelles prévu dans le
cadre de la loi les associations ont
également une responsabilité notamment
lorsqu'elle décide de défendre
publiquement un individu qui aurait fait
l'objet d'une décision de justice mais
l'écriture de la loi relève du Parlement
monsieur le député et c'est ce qu'il
fera très prochainement en examinant le
projet de loi sur l'IMM imigration qui
porte une réforme de simplification très
importante pour simplifier les
procédures et réduire de 12 à 4 les
catégories de recours le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outres mèes a équé
évoqué aussi son souhait d'entamer un
dialogue sérieux et très concerté avec
ses association je souscris évidemment
pleinement à cette démarche je vous
remercie il est
encore merci beaucoup madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Pierre-Henri
Dumont pour le complouet républicain
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre les habitants de
Calais du calisi sont inquiets inquiets
car une bombe industrielle et
environnementale se trouve en plein cœur
de ville à proximité immédiate des
habitations et d'un canal le 31 mai
dernier l'usine chimique la CC vaau so
haut saint-exime propriété du groupe
axintis a été placé en liquidation
judiciaire ces 120 employés licenciés en
portant avec eux la connaissance du site
depuis la direction d'acentis refuse non
seulement de se plier à la loi en
remettant le site de 24 hectares en état
mais est incapable de dire quel produit
chimique se trouve stocké dans des Fues
en pleine air cet été déjà deux
incidents furent constaté sur le site
sous la forme d'émanation suspecte de
fumée sur ce site se trouve aujourd'hui
1900 tonnes de déchets dont la plupart
ne sont pas encore identifiés parmi eux
nous savons néanmoins que sont
entreposés au grand A parmi les produits
les plus dangereux 15 tonnes
d'amphétamine 350 kg de bromme et 69
tonnes de canure si les amphétamines ont
été évacués ces dernières semaines le
reste décomposé chimique présent sur
site font craindre une catastrophe
industrielle et environnementale un
nouveau dazdf ou briso en plein cœur de
ma circonscription madame la Première
ministre nous ne pouvons pas vivre dans
la peur d'une telle catastrophe si
localement les représentants de l'État
ont pris le dossier à bras le corp il
est urgent que votre gouvernement agisse
rapidement pour protéger les habitants
mes questions sont donc simples tout
d'abord quelle mesure comptez-vous
prendre pour identifier puis évacuer les
1900 tonnes de déchets encore présents
sur le site dont certains sont
extrêmement dangereux et dans quel délai
ensuite comment comptez-vous financer
les évacuations de déchets puis la
remise en état du site alors que le
dirigeant de la maison mère de saintexie
maxintis n'a rempli ni ses obligations
légales ni ses obligations financières
lors de la liquidation de l'entreprise
et que ce n'est pas au contribuaes de
mettre la main à la poche pour pallier
l'incurie du chef d'entreprise enfin
allez-vous réclamer les millions d'euros
de subvention publiques accordé au
patron voyou d'acintis que ce soit pour
le site de Calais ou pour ces autres
sitres en France je vous remercie très
bien merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député du mon merci
pour votre question merci aussi pour
votre vigilance vous avez rappelé les
grandes lignes une liquidation
judiciaire au 31 mai d'un site ces
vaiseaux seuil haut et dès le début du
mois de juin mes services en l'espèce
les inspecteur de l'ICPE ont constaté
que les obligations de mise en sécurité
n'avaient pas été rempli le préfet de
manièreé immédiate a pris des arrêtés
sauf que comme la société MRE s'est
débrouillée pour ne plus être joignable
et pour ne pas avoir laissé les fonds
nécessaire pour permettre la mise en
sécurité j'ai demandé en coordination
avec le préfet à ce que l'adè au titre
de l'urgence impérieuse interviennent
pour sécuriser et pour commencer à
évacuer l'ensemble de ces déchets
dangereux les amphétamines et les 15
tonnes c'est fait les 386 kg de brome
les 69 tonnes de
cianure ce sera à compter de la
mi-novembre que les opérations de
déstockage interviendront la
particularité de ces déchets nécessit
des protocoles qui viennent d'être
validé et donc c'est à compter de la
mi-novembre ensuite il reste les 1900
tonnes de déchets qui en terme de volume
sont extrêmement importants qui feront
l'objet d'un conditionnement et d'une
sécurisation par la suite le financement
nous avons d'ors et déjà le préfet a
fait le nécessaire récupéré 805000 €
dans le cadre des garanties financières
qui vont permettre d'être directement
fléché vers laad la suite c'est que j'ai
demandé au service de l'État à la fois
en région au niveau national d'activer
l'article l512 17 du code de
l'environnement qui permet d'aller
rechercher comme vous le suggérez la
responsabilité de la maison mè accentis
dans cette histoire on ne peut pas
engranger potentiellement les résultats
quand l'usine tourne le jour elle a un
souci s'arrêter en laissant les tonnes
de déchet avec la responsabilité de
l'État pour être capable d'y faire face
il y a dans nos règles code de
l'environnement la possibilité d'aller
chercher la responsabilité de cette
maison m vous êtes entendu c'est
l'action de l'État sur le plan
gouvernemental et local dans votre
circonscription je suis à votre
disposition pour vous en donner
davantage d'explication merci beaucoup
monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane de l'autreette pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé dans la
nuit de vendredi à samedi un incendie
s'est déclaré au CHU de Limoge faisant
deux morts et deux blessés grâce à la
réactivité du service sécurité des
pompiers du 1087 des policiers et de
l'ensemble des personnels de l'hôpital
le pire a pu être évité et je tiens à
renouveler ici ma gratitude à chacun
d'entre eux monsieur le ministre je veux
d'abord vous remercier pour votre venue
à limoge samedi l'instant était bien
évidemment au recueillement mais
aujourd'hui je veux vous alerter sur la
situation dramatique dans laquelle se
trouvent les hôpitaux de haute viienne
car oui ce drame survient dans un
contexte plus que dégradé la semaine
passée les urgences du CHU ont accueilli
jusqu'à 80 patients pour seulement 15
boxes si l'engorgement est avant tout
structurel la fermeture répétée des
urgences de Saint-Junien à 30 minutes y
contribue indéblement autrement dit
comment d'un hôpital en difficulté on
aboutit à deux hôpitaux en crise
l'hôpital de Saint-Junien parlons-en
plusieurs semaines de fermeture des
urgences depuis juillet un service de
soins de suite et de réadaptation menacé
de fermeture et des personnels à bout de
force je pourrais aussi évoquer
l'hôpital de saint-thirier et bien
d'autres établissements ruraux encore
chers collègues lequel d'entre nous ne
connaît pas une telle situation sur son
territoire monsieur le ministre notre
hôpital et particulièrement nos hôpitaux
ruraux sont en urgence vitale soignants
et patients sont en souffrance absolu
les raisons vous les connaissez manque
de personnel tarification à l'acte
gouvernance inadapté et progression des
déserts médicaux ni le Ségure ni les
mesures proposées au PLFSS 2024 ne
donnent d'espoir pour nos hôpitaux de
proximité monsieur le ministre nous
attendons de vous des décisions fortes à
quand un moratoire sur la fermeture des
services ruraux de proximité à quand la
grande réforme de l'hôpital public dont
nous avons tant besoin bravo merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau ministre de
la santé et de la
prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
je souhaiterais tout d'abord m'associer
au mots que vous avez eu pour les
personnels du centre hospitalier
université de Limoge qui ont eu dans la
nuit de vendredi à samedi une réaction
exceptionnelle exceptionnel de de
courage d'abnégation et
d'efficacité puisque nous sommes passés
tout près tout près d'un RAM les
personnels du service d'incendie de
l'hôpital sont montés sans protection
resp atoire et en 15 minutes avec
également des policiers qui étaient
arrivés sur place les personnels du 10
de la Haute Vienne t les patients du
bloc de chirurgie viscérale ont été
transférés nous avons la douleur d'avoir
de connaître un bilan lourd de morts et
vous étiez nous étions ensemble quand
nous avons rencontré les équipes qui
étaient déjà à nouveau au travail samedi
mais et vous avez raison de le dire
l'héroïme auxquel on renvoie souvent les
soignants ça n'est pas ce qu'il demande
ce qu'il demande c'est de pouvoir faire
leur métier leur métier c'est le soin au
quotidien et Monsieur le Député je crois
que la version et la le tableau que vous
dressez est évidemment parti juste
beaucoup d'hôpitaux souffrent mais les
mesures qui ont été prises depuis
plusieurs années commencent à M à porter
leurs fruits nous avons connu y compris
au centre hospitalier universitaire de
Limoge qui est l'hôpital pivot pour
toute l'exrégion Limousin une campagne
de recrutement plus importante la
revalorisation annoncée par la première
ministre de 25 % du travail de nuit est
aussi un des éléments qui va permettre
de de fidéliser et le PLFSS porte une
réforme notamment pour sortir les
hôpitaux qui ne tiendraient pas par la
seule tarification à l'acte de cette
situation je ne dis pas que tout est
tout est rose loin de là mais je pense
que que nous nous pouvons saisir ces
chances et que les soignants attendent
aussi cette sérénité que nous pouvons
leur donner merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Florence
lasser pour le groupe démocrate merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les ministre mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à la
ministre des Sports madame la ministre
la Coupe du monde de rugby s'est achevée
samedi lors d'un match de finale qui a
vu l'équipe d'Afrique du Sud conserver
son titre si bien sûr nous ont tous
souhaité sur ces bancs voir nos bleus
aller plus loin nous ne pouvons qu'être
fiers et nous féliciter du formidable
engouement qu'ils ont suscité tout au
long de ces semaines depuis le march
d'ouverture depuis sa nomination en tant
que pays haute en 2017 jusqu'à son point
final notre pays n'a pas manqué à sa
réputation tant pour l'esprit dans
lequel il a accueilli les centaines de
milliers de supporters du monde entier
depuis la fraternisation d'avant pendant
d'après match jusqu'à la diffusion de
notre magnifique hymne de l'Aviron
Bayonnais que pour la gestion logistique
de cet
événement nos infrastructure de
transport aérien ferroviaire de
transport en commun tout comme
l'hébergement ont démontré leur capacité
à absorber un flux aussi
important nos forces de sécurité ont
permis à la compétition de se dérouler
dans les meilleures conditions je crois
que nous pvons les féliciter et les
enercier pays sont d'ors et déjà
positives aussi bien en terme économique
qu'en terme d'image et cela est de bon
augure pour le futur madame la ministre
avec les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de l'été prochain d'autres
échéances d'une ampleur encore plus
grande s'annonce aussi quel bilan
dressez-vous de cet événement et quels
sont les points qui vous semblent devoir
retenir notre attention pour que
l'organisation de ces jeux soit à
l'image de cette coupe du monde de rugby
je vous remercie merci beaucoup la
parole est à Madame madame Amélie ouea
Castera ministre des Sports des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la député la sererre par
de là le déchirement en effet de
l'élimination du 15 de France contre les
futurs vainqueurs oui cet événement aura
été un formidable succès avec d'abord
des records battus beaucoup de records
battus de fréquentation dans les stades
avec 2,4 millions de spectateurs dans
les fan zones avec 1,6 million de
spectateurs et même la meilleure
audience télé de l'année en France pour
ce match France Afrique du Sud tout
programme confondu on a accueilli 600000
visiteurs du monde entier avec une
organisation fluide efficace et
parfaitement coordonnée entre toutes les
parties prenantes qui a permis passer
les premiers rages du début de délivrer
une expérience à la hauteur de
l'événement cette coupe du monde elle a
été aussi organisée avec des standards
particulièrement élevés en matière
sociale écologique d'inclusion avec un
impact positif sur le plan économique
pour nos territoires et un héritage déjà
effectif sur la pratique sportive et sur
les métiers du sport alors oui cet
événement est aussi riche d'enseignement
pour la suite beaucoup d'enseignements
positifs d'abord en matière de sécurité
le dispositif piloté par gerérald
haranin a fait la preuve de sa
robustesse en dépit d'un contexte
particulièrement exigeant en matière de
transport nous avons su adapter sous le
pilotage de Clément baun des renforts de
capacité
d'effectifs avec les opérateurs de
transport en pleine coordination avec
ceci que je salue en matière
d'engagement populaire on a su avec les
collectivités mettre en place un bon
modèle de fan zone dont on va s'inspirer
pour les jeux au titre des améliorations
en plus du travail qui se poursuit sur
l'accessibilité de nos infrastructures
la gestion opérationnel des flux de
spectateurs et le point sur lequel nous
avons le plus progressé en cours
d'événement pour mieux guider les
spectateurs étrangers pour affiner
l'information voyageur optimiser le
positionnement des volontaires sur les
parcours dans leur orientation cette
agilité collective elle s'est aiguisée
au fil des matchs elle sera un acquis
pour les jeux avec cette coupe du monde
on a fait rayonner notre pays on va
continuer à faire émerger une nouvelle
référence d'événements sportifs plus
sobre plus responsable et plus solidaire
je vous remercie merci beaucoup madame
la ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Vincent Rolland pour le group les
républicain merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre l'hiver
approchant
permettez-moi attirer votre attention
sur un sujet du quotidien pour nos
concitoyens qui habitent en zone de
montagne celui de la sécurité routière
et des déplacements sur nos routes
enneigées en décembre 2016 le
législateur pensait y avoir répandu dans
l'acte 2 de la loi montagne il
s'agissait de l'obligation pour tout
véhicule se déplaçant depuis vert entre
des communes de montagn d'être équipé de
pneu neige ou quatre saisons ou à minima
de posséder des chaînes ou chaussettes
dans le coffre permettant d'affronter
les conditions climatique avec un niveau
de sécurité et de motricité
renforcé rapporteur pour l'évaluation de
l'application de cette loi en 2020 avec
Marie- Noël baptistel nous vous avions
pourtant informé de cette non
apppplication il nous avait d'ailleurs
été répondu que ce serait imminent or 3
ans plus tard à la veille de son entrée
en vigueur demain le 1er novembre le
décret d'application n'est toujours pas
connu je ne vous cache pas qu'il règne
une certaine confusion autour de cette
obligation madame la Première ministre
pouvez-vous nous éclairer sur la suite
donnée à ce dossier et clarifier la
position des assureurs en cas d'accident
impliquant des véhicules ne possédant
pas les équipements requis pour u sur
nos routes de montagne l'économie du
tourisme est essentielle en zone de
montagne mais encore faut-il respectter
le quotidien de celles et ceux qui
vivent et qui travaillent chaque jour je
vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Roland en l'absence
de mon ministre délégé au transport
Clément bun j'ai la joie de vous
répondre sur un sujet que je sais que
vous maîtrisez particulièrement à la
fois contenu de la circonscription que
vous représentez mais de ce que vous
avez évoqué par le passé 34 départements
à comptter de demain sont concernés par
des arrêtés préfectoraux pour au moins
une de leurs communes et pour
l'obligation du 1er novembre au 31 mars
je ne reprends pas tout ce que vous avez
indiqué d'être où équipé ou d'avoir ce
qu'il faut dans le coffre et cetera à
l'instar d'ailleurs de 18 pays européens
sur les 27 que compte l'Union européenne
l'objectif premier avant d'être de la
répression c'est bien de la sécurité et
tous ceux qui ont voté ce texte tous
ceux qui l'ont porté le savent c'est la
première cause d'accident qui provoque
les blocages auquel vous faites
référence compte tenu ensuite des
conséquences économiques qu'elles
peuvent avoir mais dans un premier temps
tout simplement des risques pour les
femmes et les hommes qui circulent dans
ces véhicules d'être eux-mêmes
blessés à la minute où nous parlons il
n'y a pas de décret créant la sanction
dans le cadre du code de la route pour
le non respect de cette obligation la
visée
pédagogique a conduit à ce que jusqu'à
maintenant nous procédions à des
contrôles et dans l'hiver qui commence
demain d'un point de vue administratif
ce que je peux vous annoncer dans
l'application des règles hivernales qui
commence à compter du 1er novembre nous
nous tenons prêt à dégainer ce décret si
les contrôles montrent que nous n'avons
pas des taux d'équipement suffisants de
la part des automobiliste il a été
souhaité qu'on laisse de années pleines
pour que les gens s'habituent à la
réglementation et ce décret pourrait
être pris dans l'hiver qui arrive les
services du ministère délégué au
transport et les miens se tiennent à
votre
disposition merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre Monsieur Roland oui monsieur le
ministre à partir de quel pourcentage
peut-on considérer que nos concitoyens
respectent la loi ou à défaut prendre un
décret si jamais ça n'était pas le cas
quel est le pourcentage que vous estimez
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Benz pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Économie Bruno Lemire monsieur le
ministre sur le grave problème de la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat qui frappe
très durement les Français depuis trop
longtemps on ne vous lâchera pas on ne
vous lâchera pas car les Français vous
hurlent leurs désarrois et leurs
inquiétude mais vous ne les écoutez pas
les députés du rassemblement national
sont là pour vous le rappeler chaque
jour si besoin les Français souffrent
ils sont malheureusement de plus en plus
nombreux dans un contexte de crise
économique sévère et de crise
inflationniste inédite les Français
veulent des actions concrètes des
mesures fortes exceptionnelles pour
certaines durable pour les autres en
tout cas efficace et surtout au plus
vite pour se nourrir pour se soigner
pour se chauffer pour se déplacer bref
pour vivre une vie digne en France au
21e siècle la peur de la fin du mois est
une préoccupation majeure pour des
millions de Français et elle est
parfaitement légitime depuis des mois
nous réclamons des mesures simples
alimentation énergie soins transport
voilà les priorités sur lesquelles
Marine Le Pen a fait de nombreuses
propositions concrètes aux effets
immédiats lors de la
présidentielle pour le moment vous
exercez encore le pouvoir faut-il que
les Français attendent 2027 pour que
nous mettions nous enfin en place les
mesures de bon sens pour améliorer leur
quotidien et rendre à nos concitoyens la
vie plus simple et une vie plus douce
par avance je vous en prie ne nous
répondez pas encore comme d'habitude que
tout va bien que vous avez raison que
vous faites tout bien que vous êtes les
meilleurs les Français méritent mieux
que de la communication gouvernementale
il ne vous demande qu'une seule chose
agissez avec rapidité et efficacité je
vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole à
Madame Olivia grégoard ministre en
charge des petites et moyennes
entreprises du commerce de l'artisanat
et du
tourisme merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
Christophe
Bens vous m'autoriserez à vous
parapraser parce que nous non plus nous
ne lâcherons pas nous ne lâcherons pas
ce que nous avons enclenché depuis 6 ans
au service des Français et que vous ne
voulez pas entendre nous ne lâcherons
pas tour de l'emploi dans notre pays
avec plus d'un million et demi d'emplois
créer depuis 2017 nous ne lâcherons pas
la réindustrialisation de ce pays avec
300 usines je sais ça vous fatigue
monsieur Tangui mais c'est la vérité 300
usines qui ont réouvert leurs portes
depuis 2017 pas moins de 90000 emplois
industriels à nouveau créés nous ne
lâcherons pas le partage de la valeur
que les députés de la majorité ont porté
avec force je sais que ça vous paraît
peu c'est quasiment 5 milliards c'est 4
millions et demi de salariés qui ont vu
800 € de plus cette année nous ne
lâcherons pas la croissance qui au 3è
trimestre dans un contexte très
difficile est encore au rendez-vous nous
ne lâcherons pas ce que nous faisons
pour accompagner les Français du
bouclier tarifaire à l'indemnité pour
ceux qui ont des difficultés à se
déplacer en voiture avec le prix des
carburants nous ne lâcherons pas notre
combat avec Bruno lumer contre
l'inflation alimentaire dont vous avez
oublié de dire
depuis ce matin qu'elle est passé sous
la barre des 8% et que l'inflation
glissante est à 4 % nous ne lâcherons
pas l'investissement des entreprises
1,5 % d'investissement en plus je sais
ça ne fait pas vos affaires mais c'est
la réalité du tableau économique de la
France nous ne lâcherons pas non plus la
consommation des ménages qui tient qui
résiste ça vous ennuie mais elle tient
plus 07 % encore ça n'est pas la
question êre les meilleurs n'est pas la
question d'avoir raison c'est la
question de regarder le tableau
économique de la France tel qu'il est et
ce qui ne fait pas vos affaires c'est
que nous n'entrenons pas le désespoir
mais bel et bien l'optimisme
contrairement à d'autres merci merci
beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame
Farida pour la France insoumise merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre le 27 juin dernier les
quartiers populaires se révoltaient
après la mort un entre du jeune Naël tué
par un policier cet événement s'inscrit
dans le cadre d'une multiplication des
violences pour refus d'obtempéré
favorisé par l'adoption de la loi case
neu depuis 2017 les tirs mortels sur les
véhicules ont été multipliés par 5 en
2022 13 personnes ont été tuées dès lors
comme comme en 2005 le soulèvement des
quartiers populaire est une révolte
politique pourtant jeudi à la à la
Sorbonne vousnon vous annonciez en
grande pompe des réponses 100 %
répressives sanction pour les parents
création de centes d'encadrement par les
militaires nouveau pouvoir pour la
police municipale en
minimisant en misant sur tout le
sécuritaire pardon en plutôt que
l'abrogation de la loi cas ne vous
refusez vous refusez d'entendre les
revendications
exprimées plutôt que de pénaliser les
parents et de réprimer les enfants
renforcer au services publics trois
d'entre eux sont toujours menacés
d'effondrement l'éducation alors il est
anormal que dans ma circonscription des
enfants de moins de 16 ans soient chaque
année sans affectation et donc livrés à
eux-mêmes la santé à l'heure où nos
hôpitaux tombent en ruine et où nos
quartiers deviennent peu à peu des
déserts médicaux la sécurité enfin alors
que le lien de confiance entre la police
et la population est désormais rompu
madame la Première ministre quand
allez-vous élaborer avec les acteurs de
terrain et les élus de proximité unact
social ambitieux pour nos quartiers
populaires merci beaucoup ma cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier verrand porte-parole du
gouvernement et en charge du renouveau
démocratique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Farida Amrani il y aurait
beaucoup de choses à dire sur le constat
que vous faites et que je ne partage pas
notamment sur l'origine politique des
émeutes urbaines qu' a connu la France
vous le comparez à 2000 2005 moi je ne
suis pas d'accord je considère que s'il
y a eu un drame initial la motivation
d'ailleurs les enquêtes de police et et
de justice l'ont montré dans moins de 10
% des cas le la situation du jeune Naël
a été évoquée par les hmetiers je pense
qu'il faut pas tout mélanger et je crois
que dans les mouvements qu'on connu un
certain nombre de villes et de quartiers
populaires de nos villes françaises faut
pas y voir forcément de la révolte
politique en tout cas c'est pas mon cas
néanmoins madame la députée après avoir
dans un premier temps montré qu'on était
capable de rétablir l'ordre d'arrêter
les fauteurs de trouble et de punir et
bien c'est posé la question de savoir ce
que nous faisions dans la durée pour les
quartiers populaires d'abord pour éviter
qu'il y ait des nouvelles am urbaine et
puis ensuite pour arriver dans le cadre
de la politique qu'on appelle le CIV qui
est le communité interministériel des
villes à savoir comment est-ce qu'on
continue de développer une politique à
destination des quers des quartiers
prioritaires quand vous dites que tout
est 100 % répressif je je veux bien
qu'on soit dans l'émicycle qu'on fasse
des vidéos sur les réseaux sociaux on on
doit être capable de se parler quand
même madame la députée et qu'est-ce
qu'il y a de répressif dans le fait
madame la députée qu'on ouvre au collège
de 8h à 18h dans les quartiers
prioritaires qu'est-ce que c'est de tout
répressif quand la Première ministre
annonce une politique de testing pour
lutter contre les discriminations à
l'embauche ou à l'accès au prêt
immobilier qu'est-ce qu'il y a de 100 %
répressif lorsqu'on met en place un plan
entrepreneuriat quartier 2030 pour aider
justement les jeunes qui on du talent
dans nos quartiers à arriver à investir
et entreprendre je veux dire il faut
qu'on sorte des slogans en permanence
parce que les gens qui vous écoutent ont
l'impression qu'on s'occupe pas d'eux
alors qu'en réalité on s'occupe d'eux et
c'est des choses sur lesquelles on peut
se retrouver de la même manière madame
la députée jeis élu d'une d'une
circonscription que vous connaissez
puisquelle est gérée par la France
insoumise Grenoble vous voulez qu'on
parle du bilan grenoblois depuis la
franceç insoumise la France insoumise
est au pouvoir je vois madame la députée
qui est là il y a plus de rénovation
urbaine il y a plus de programme en rue
on laisse les pauvres s'entasser dans
les quartiers on met même plus d'eau sur
les places des marchés des quartier pop
donc regardez ce que vous faites là où
vous gagnez ensuite donnez-ous des son
merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe
Emmanuel allez-y ma cher transparente
mais quand même j'existe donc monsieur
le ministre vraiment franchement ce
qu'attendent nos jeunes et il y a du
talent dans nos quartiers et moi ce que
je vois c'est pas du tout ce que vous
êtes en train de me décrire donc du coup
monsieur le ministre je vous invite
vraiment à venir dans mon dans les
quartiers populaires de ma
circonscription chich venez donnez-nous
rendez-vous et allons-y
ensemble je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Philippe Emmanuel pour le
group naissance merci madame la
Présidente cette question s'adresse à
Monsieur monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald
armanin monsieur le ministre la Coupe du
monde de rugby vient de s'achever par
une finale de titan entre la
Nouvelle-Zélande et l'Afrique du Sud si
beaucoup de Français comme moi auraient
aimé voir notre 15 nationales aller plus
loin dans la compétition l'engoument du
public s'est confirmé avec plus de 3,4
millions de spectateurs dans H stades
différents sur tout le territoire un peu
plus si on ajoute les fan
zones nous pouvons vous féliciter
Monsieur le Ministre ainsi que tous ceux
qui ont contribué à ce très beau
succès tant au niveau de l'organisation
que de la sécurité malheureusement les
incidents de dimanche qui ont conduit à
l'annulation du match de foot
omol démontre que rien n'est
acquis ma question concerne la sécurité
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris
2024 fort du succès construit avec le
rugby pouvez-vous nous faire un point
monsieur le ministre sur les moyens qui
seront mis en œuvre pour la sécurité des
JO à venir
merci je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald daranin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outre
maire merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député merci pour les
policiers les gendarmes les agents
militaires de sentinelle pour les agents
de sécurité privée également qui ont
garantti la ministre des sport l'a dit
une très belle coupe du monde de rugby
si joset je voulais dire qu'il y a les
bleus sur le terrain et nous avons
supporté notre équipe et puis a les
Bleus en dehors du terrain qui ont gagné
la Coupe du Monde de la sécurité puisque
n pu nous avons pu accueillir des
centaines de milliers de personnes 2
millions de visiteurs partout sur le
territoire national avec des opérations
zéro délinquence 4900 opérations avec
plus de 800 interpellations malgré tout
avec 500 alertes à la bombe qui
évidemment on pour essayer de
désorganiser la Coupe du monde et en
même temps le pape à Marseille en même
temps le roi et la reine d'Angleterre en
France et en même temps les risques
terroristes que nous connaissons donc
merci pour les policiers les gendarmes
les préfets et les militaires de de
sentinelle c'est effectivement une
réussite que nous pouvons en effet
évoqué comme étant une réussite d'abord
du système de sécurité français pour les
Jeux Olympiques et pour les Jeux
paralympiques il y a évidemment encore à
travailler d'abord sur la sécurité
privée même si là nous avons eu que 3 %
de défaillant agents de sécurité privée
donc ils ont donc été au rendez-vous que
ce soit dans les stades ou en dehors des
stades il y a un travail évidemment à
faire contre les cybers atttaques vous
le savez 4 milliards de cyberattaques
pendant les Jeux de Tokyo alors qu'il y
avait le covid il faut donc y travailler
sous l'autorité de la première ministre
les drones et notamment les drones
malveillants plus d'une vingtaine de
drones malveillants ont été arrêtés
neutralisés grâce à la loi que vous avez
voté d'ailleurs monsieur le député
pendant la couponde de rugby ils vont se
multiplier évidemment pendant les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et puis la
lutte contre la délinquence o vous le
savez il y a une mobilisation sans
précédent des policiers des gendarmes
entre juin débarquement de Normandie
jusqu'à septembre c'est-à-dire jeux
paralympiqu où les policiers gendarmes
font un effort sans précédent de congés
reporté de présence et de présence MIF
grâce à la loi que vous avez voté
puisque nous avons 8000 policiers
gendarmes supplémentaires pour garantir
ces Jeux Olympiques merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre mon cher collègue
oui je voulais juste ajouter à vos mots
monsieur le ministre mes remerciements
aussi aux forces de police que je visite
régulièrement force de police de
gendarmerie et de pompiers dans ma
circonscription et je sais qu'il se
prépare merci merci beaucoup la parole
est à Madame Martine Froger pour le
groupe
lot merci madame la Présidente ma
question ma question s'adresse à la
ministre des collectivités territoriales
et de la ruralité madame la ministre le
gouvernement a entrepris de réformer et
de fusionner les différents zonages dans
un dispositif appelé maintenant France
ruralité revitalisation qui doit entrer
en en application en juillet 2024 le
niveau dispositif qui modifie un certain
nombre de critères va impacter de
nombreuses communes partout en France le
chiffre parle de lui-même on passerait
de 17000 communes bénéficiaires à 14000
soit une exclusion de 20 % des communes
actuellement bénéficiaires chez moi en
Ariège les élus et les entreprises
installées sur ces zones sont inquiets
comment rassurer les communes qui vont
sortir du dispositif au regard des
critères de revenu médian par habit et
la hausse démographique dans un contexte
d'aggravation de la fracture
territoriale c'est là un très mauvais
message adressé aux départements les
plus ruraux ce dispositif et son zonage
constitue un alément d'attractivité
indéniable sur lequel s'appui largement
les communes du département de laarège
les élus sont donc fortement attachés à
cet outil de soutien au développement
des territoires ruraux conçu comme un
dispositif symbole d'équité territoriale
au-delà de cette réforme ponctuelle il
devient urgent de réfléchir
collectivement pour définir les axentiel
d'une politique d'aménagement du
territoire efficace au service du bien
commun alors madame la ministre mes
questions sont simples comment
comptez-vous rassurer les communes
sortantes du dispositif actuel de ZRR et
quelle mesure d'accompagnement
entendez-vous prendre pour éviter à pour
éviter à ces territoires d'être
fragilisés davantage encore par ce
désengagement de l'État plus largement
ne pourrait-on pas réintégrer certaines
communes qui doivent sortir du
dispositif en prenant en compte la
particularité géographique des
territoires et notamment les handicaps
naturels je vous remercie merci beaucoup
ma cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée
Froger Dominique fort qui a porté cette
ce projet France ruralité étant retenu
en audition j'ai la joie de vous
répondre cet après-midi d'abord partons
du début ce dispositif de ZRR il était
censé s'éteindre le 31 décembre 2021 il
vient d'être prolongé deux fois de suite
dans le cadre des lois de finances
initiales et la première ministre
Elisabeth borne a pris l'année dernière
en novembre dernier un engagement
solennel devant l'Association des maires
de France en disant que nous allions
conserver un zonage spécifique et plus
qu'un zonage créer même un zonage
spécifique parce qu'on avait jusqu'à
maintenant un zoneage unique mais avec
l'idée qu'on avait parfois besoin
d'aller plus loin que les zones de
revitalisation rurale avec une sorte de
dispositif ZRR plus ou FRR plus pour
reprendre le nouveau cycle la
disposition que vous évoquez c'est
l'article 7 initial du projet de loi de
finance 2024 avant qu'il n'arrive dans
cette assemblée avant qu'il ne soit
débattu ici puis au Sénat et nous savons
les attentes d'une partie des
parlementaires sur le sujet qu'est-ce
qu'il y a à la minute où nous parlons
six départements qui sont intégralement
zonés je sais le Cantal
l'Indre la Creuse la hauteemarne la
Meuse et la Nièvre je sais que la lozer
l' rège ou hasard considère qu'il
devrait faire partie de du même groupe
nous avons aujourd'hui retenu un critère
de déprise démographique supérieur à 4 %
sur une période de 10 ans à ça s'ajoute
des communes avec le maintien d'une
maille intercommunale et avec une
nouveauté qui est la possibilité pour
les préfets d'aller rattraper des
communes à une maille communale si leur
richesse ou leur densité lié à
l'intercommunalité dans laquelle elle
elle se situe ne bénéficie pas du
dispositif nous faisons confiance au
dialogue avec les parlementaire ici pour
regarder si ce dispositif est
parfaitement adapté ou s'il doit être
légèrement recalibré merci pour votre
question merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
William Martinet pour le groupe la
France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre du Logement
monsieur le ministre gouverner c'est
d'abord loger son peuple cette citation
de l'abbis Pierre a plus d'un
demi-siècle et pourtant elle raisonne
avec force aujourd'hui elle rappelle
votre échec les locataires sont assommés
par les hausses de loyers que vous avez
décidé 3,5 % l'année dernière 3,5 %
cette année depuis que le Président
Macron a été réélu il faut payer
l'équivalent d'un 13e mois de loyer
c'est une honte les augmentations de
charges sont astronomi jusqu'à 200 ou
300 % votre bouclier tarifaire ne
protège pas les gens il protège les
super profits des multinationales de
l'énergie c'est une honte des milliers
d'étudiants dorment au camping à
l'auberge de jeunesse où doivent
renoncer à leurs études votre refus de
construire des logements CROUS les a
empêché de choisir leur vie c'est une
honte les habitants du littoral voient
leur logement confisqués par Airbnb et
les résidences secondair les enfants du
pays restent à la rue pendant que les
multipropriétaires dictent leur loi
c'est une honte
tout cela monsieur le ministre c'est
votre bilan la macronie a mené une
politique d'austérité qui a tout détruit
c'est une saignée historique l'effort
public pour le logement n'a jamais été
aussi bas depuis les années 70 en 2017
vous nous promettiez un choc de l'offre
mais monsieur le ministre le seul choc
qui a eu lieu c'est le choc de la misère
en cette rentrée 2800 enfants dorment à
la rue deux fois plus que l'année
dernière mais vous ne comptez rien faire
pas même ouvrir les 10000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence demandé par les
associations pour sortir de la crise du
logement il faut d'abord sortir de la
logique libérale sortir de la
financiarisation il y a une solution
monsieur le ministre le retour de l'État
un état qui investit pour construire des
logements sociaux dont nous avons besoin
un état qui finance la rénovation des
logements pour tenir nos engagements
écologiques un état qui régule les prix
des loyers et du foncier pour garantir
le logement abordable gouverner c'est
d'abord loger son peuple monsieur le
ministre si vous ne vous en sentez pas
capable laissez-nous faire
bravo je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Patrice vergrit ministre en
charge du
logement madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député
Martinet l'accord que nous avons passé
avec le mouvement HLM à Nant témoigne de
l'engagement du gouvernement en
direction du logement social je vous en
rappelle quelques chiffres 1,2 milliards
pour accompagner la rénovation
énergétiqu des logements locatifs
sociaux dans les 3 ans qui viennent et 8
milliards de prêts bonifiés de la Caisse
des Dépôts équivalent à 650 millions de
charges et si le mouvement Hlm a bien
signé cet accord c'est parce qu'il est
substantiel justement pour pouvoir tenir
deux engagements majeurs la rénovation
énergétique des logements sociaux qui
est indispensable pour le confort et le
boir d'achat des locataires et également
la production de logements
sociaux vous évoquez les loyers les
loyers effectivement ont été plafonnés à
3,5% au lieu de 6 au lieu de 6 % sans le
plafonnement et les APL ont été alignés
sur ce même 3,5 % ce qui permet
effectivement au locatair qui
bénéficient d'APL de pouvoir effacer
cette hausse mais je voudrais aller plus
loin avec vous monsieur le député
aujourd'hui c'est intéressant de mesurer
les taux d'effort de nos concitoyens
dans le logement social comparativement
au logement privé le premier décile en
particulier de nos concitoyens
c'est-à-dire les plus pauvres dans le
logement locatif social le taux d'effort
est de 29 % il est de 52 % pour le même
décile dans le parc privé et oui c'est
pour ça monsieur le député qu'il est
absolument indispensable de garder le
logement locatif social de le protéger
comme nous le faisons mais aussi de
mettre l'accent pour accompagner les
logements locatifs dans le parc privé
également m'interroger également sur
l'hébergement du
aucun gouvernement n'a fait comme
celui-ci le plan logement d'abord
reconnu par toutes les associations un
passage de 93000 place à 203000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence jamais aucun
gouvernement n'a fait cet engagement
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Pierre pont
pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse au ministre de la
santé et de la prévention monsieur le
ministre selon l'Agence nationale de la
sécurité du médicament plus plus de 3700
ruptures ou risque de rupture de
médicaments sont recensés sur le sol
français en 2022 contre moins de 200 en
2012 cette année les pathologies
hivernales ne sont pas encore arrivées
et il y a déjà une pénurie
d'antibiotique comme laamoxicyine dans
plusieurs régions et plus
particulièrement dans les haut de France
et dans le sud-est les causes de ces
pénuries sont multiple et conjoncturel
avec la guerre en Ukraine et une
explosion de la consommation chinoise de
médicaments
en cause également une extrême
concentration de la production en effet
certains médicaments sont fabriqués
uniquement par une seule entreprise
rendant très fragile la la chaîne de
distribution cette pénurie dernière
pénurie le vaccin contre la bruciolite
des bébés est déjà en rupture de stock
la commande effective de 200000 doses ne
peut pouvoir semblet-il répondre à la
forte demande actuelle le gouverne ement
vient d'annoncer récemment une
relocalisation des entreprises et son
intention de rendre obligatoire la vente
de certains antibiotiques à l'unité pour
réduire le gaspillage une commission
d'enquête du Sénat de juillet 2023
esquise des pistes pour sortir de cette
situation comme la mise en place d'une
production européenne des médicaments
essentiels pour répondre à cette pénurie
urgente de médicaments je vous serai
reconnaissant monsieur le ministre de
bien vouloir nous faire connaître les
mesures que vous comptez prendre
rapidement je vous remercie merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau ministre de
la santé et de la prévention madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député oui nous
avons connu l'an dernier une extrêmement
forte pénurie de médicaments et nous
connaissons à nouveau cette année des
tensions sur certains produits pour
répondre très directement à votre
question j'ai mandaté l'Agence nationale
de sécurité du médicament qui suit 450
des médicaments prioritaires dont la
moxiciline et qui vous l'avez sans doute
vu s'est vu renforcer ses pouvoirs de
police sanitaire notamment pour essayer
quand il y a du blocage dans le circuit
de distribution d'assurer que les les
médicaments arrivent bien dans toutes
les pharmacies alors que au niveau
global nous avons des stocks et donc le
sujet c'est bien de suivre à chaque
étape l'industriel le grossiste
répartiteur le pharmacien jusqu'au
patient pour savoir où se situent ces
blocages mais vous avez raison aussi
Monsieur le le député pont de le
souligner tous les pays d'Europe
connaissent ces difficultés ça ne veut
pas dire qu'on reste les bras croisés
nous avons proposé notamment sur la
moxicyine en échange d'une garantie par
les industriels qui sont en effet très
concentrés de de volume de livraison à
la France une augmentation des prix qui
n'a pas d'impact sur le prix payé par le
consommateur par le patient et donc nous
avons aujourd'hui des stocks qui sur le
plan global sont satisfaisants et nous
avons des régions vous les avez cité où
l'accès est difficile je réunirai la
semaine prochaine tous les industriels
les grossistes répartiteurs et les
représentants des pharmacies pour
comprendre pour et mettre en œuvre tous
les moyens nécessaires pour assurer ce
déblocage et par ailleurs deux remarques
complémentaires nous avons ciblé 25
médicaments essentiels le président de
la République s'est engagé dans une
visite à ardèch a engagé leur
relocalisation et je m'assure auprès des
industriels qu'ils tiendront leurs
engagements c'est un point essentiel et
sur le bfortus croyz cro bien tous les
jours nous essayons notamment avec la
première ministre de compléter cette
livraison à la France de 200000 qui est
déjà la plus grosse livraison pour un
pays d'Europe merci monsieur le député
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame ménage pour le
rassemblement
national merciés présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé Rousseau il n'y a pas un sujet où
ce gouvernement ne fasse l'autruche
niant en parlement son rôle de contrôle
interdisant au français un débat
équitable en détournant systématiquement
la disposition 493 de notre Constitution
ce gouvernement nous le savons
maintenant a en horreur le dialogue et
la sincérité le 13 juin dernier
j'aiinrogais ce ministère qui est le
vôtre quant à la politique inavouée de
fermeture des maternités vos équipes
m'informer alors ne pas suivre les
préconisations de l'Académie de médecine
ne pas avoir je cite de politique
volontariste de fermeture des
établissements de santé depuis 2000 le
taux de fécondité des Français est
inchangé pourtant ce sont aujourd'hui
111 maternités que vous voulez fermer
comme le soulligne le syndicat des
gynécologues qui pointe du doigt cette
catastrophe dont vous niz la
responsabilité
entre autres la maternité de pon déjà
close et la prochaine à suivre sera
celle dancen vous ne pouvez pas nier
conduire cette politique de fermeture au
prétexte du risque d'un service mal
calibré risque que vous transposé et
accentué par la saturation des CHU
engorgé par ces mamans qui doivent faire
près d'une heure de route pour mettre au
monde leurs enfant votre argument idiot
n'est que paradoxe et contradiction avec
le réel comme d'habitude alors je vous
le demande monsieur le ministre
comptez-vous continuer cette
transformation des services publics en
organismes prestataires de servicees où
seuls vos bureaucrates sont en
compétition pour plaire à votre régime
où ils promuvent leur carrière par le
même dénis les mêmes trahisons et la
même feinte permanente du bon sens par
la caricature du raisonnement si c'est
le cas alors on ne baigne plus seulement
dans le dans le cynisme mais on pâuge
dans
l'imbécilité merci beaucoup la parole
est à Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
merci de cettera question vraiment tout
en nuance
euh la maternité de Peron dont vous me
parlez euh a réalisé cette année jusqu'à
la suspension de son activité faute d'un
anesthésiste réanimateur qui permettent
d'assurer la continuité des soins elle a
réalisé jusqu'au début octobre 96
accouchements 96 accouchements je vais
vous dire quelque chose madame la
députée c'est peut-être techno imbécile
ou un des adjectifs que vous avez
employé la médecine c'est un art dans
lequel il faut savoir faire les gestes
les gestes qui sauvent il faut savoir
les faire parce qu'on les rencontre
plusieurs fois dans une journée
plusieurs fois dans une semaine 96
accouchement jamais nous n'avons cherché
à fermer cette maternité il se trouve
que ça signifie quand même un
accouchement tous les 3 jours ça
signifie que une éclampsie je voudrais
être sûr que le gynécologue soit capable
d'intervenir assez vite et donc entre la
promesse que vous faites vaguement
d'égalité
et le fait de savoir que une parturiante
elle sera prise en charge et que son
bébé et elle-même ne mourront pas en
couche il y a une différence entre nous
en effet vous dans votre monde alleer à
Saint-Quentin ou à Amien c'est un
déchirement je comprends que ça puisse
être un déchirement mais moi mon
déchirement c'est si sur vos arguments
politiciens la variable d'ajustement
c'est la santé et la sécurité des soins
ça je ne m'y résoudrai jamais je ne me
résoudrai jamais à fire service pour des
questions de finan le 111 que vous
évoquez je ne vois pas à quoi vous
faites référence mais je ne me résoudrai
jamais à laisser ouvert un service dans
lequel je ne conseillerai à aucun de vos
collègues ou à quiconque de se rendre
pour faire pour faire accoucher sa
famille donc oui il y a un principe ser
sécurité santé sécurité des soins c'est
ça le la promesse républicaine avant
tout madame la
députée je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre madame la
députée com prend bien votre seule
réponse au manque de personnel soignant
c'est la fermeture des maternités des
hôpitaux alors j'ai qu'une seule chose à
dire vivement 2027 que Marine Le Pen
soit élue
merci je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur thry bonoî pour le groupe au
raison merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de
l'Agriculture je voudrais aborder avec
vous la mise en œuvre de la politique
agricole commune dans le délai
2023-2027 et plus particulièrement la
question des mesures Agri
environnementales et climatiqu jusqu'à
2022 c'était les régions qui qui étaient
les autorités de gestion de ces fonds
européens et combiné à des crédits
publics d'état des régions de l'Agence
de l'eau ça permettait aux agriculteurs
qui s'engage dans des pratiques
vertueuses notamment dans le domaine de
l'élevage particulier ulrement en
Bretagne d'engager leur profession vers
la transition écologique pour ce qui est
du programme
2023227 l'état approvisionné environ 90
millions d'euros la direction régionale
de l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et
de la forêt en Bretagne prévoit 150
millions il y a donc rien que pour la
région Bretagne un delta de 60 millions
région de France estime cette ce manque
pour le territoire national à peu près à
250 300 millions les mesures
agro-environnemental et climatique c'est
un contrat entre les agriculteurs et la
puissance publique pour embarquer
l'agriculture vers la transition
écologique on ne peut donc pas se
manquer se louper lorsque c'était les
régions qui pilotaient ce projet ce
dispositif ça fonctionnait bien monsieur
le ministre de l'Agriculture depuis
longtemps on vous alerte depuis
septembre en commission des affaires
économiques on en a beaucoup débattu
vous avez reçu des courriers de
parlementaires il faut à tout prix que
vous vous saisissiez de cette question
et c'est sous votre autorité que
l'ensemble des partenaires doivent se
mobiliser pour accorder ces financements
il n'y aurait rien de pire que de
démontrer que lorsque c'est l'État qui
gère les crédits européens c'est un
échec ce serait aussi une façon de faire
détester la politique agricole commune
alors que pour la agriculture particuli
BR merci la parole est à Monsieur Marc
PHENO ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Benoît merci de votre question qui va me
permettre de compléter la réponse que
j'ai fait tout à l'heure à votre
collègue mollac et saluer la
mobilisation d'un certain nombre de vos
collègues enfin la totalité je crois des
collègues de Bretagne sur cette question
des Mikes comme on dit de ce pilier
important de la PAC je rappelle ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure d'abord la
politique agricole commune dans
l'ensemble de ces politiques que nous
avons posé pour la période 2023- 20027
il y a la volonté de faciliter
d'accélérer de renforcer le volet des
transitions c'est l'écorégime c'est la
conversion en agriculture biologique et
les ma font partie du dispositif deuxème
élément il a quelque chose que pardon de
le dire comme ça je suis élu régional je
suis un territorial vous le savez
monsieur le député le sujet n'est pas de
savoir qui gère le sujet c'est que sur
la précédente programmation nous avions
2500 55 millions de crédits qui étaient
prévus sur les ma que nous avons
provisionné 260 millions d'euros mais je
peux pas me retrouver et j'en appelle un
peu à la responsabilité dans une
situation on me disent c'est pas 260
c'est 500 qu'il faut parce que ce n'est
pas une politique de guichet la
politique des Mac et donc on a besoin de
trouver un chemin qui permette entre les
exigence qui avaient été posé le cadre
budgétaire que tout le monde connaissait
qui était de 250 millions d'euros de
regarder ce qu'on peut faire pour
essayer de répondre vous avez raison et
de ne pas décourager les agriculteurs
qui veulent s'engager sur ces politiques
j'ai évoqué deux pistes tout à l' à
l'heure la région Bretagne a beaucoup de
mobiliser les Maek et c'est une bonne
chose parce qu'effectivement ça permet
de faire évoluer les systèmes sur le
carbone sur la biodiversité sur l'eau et
donc on sait que c'est important et donc
on sera au rendez-vous comme on l'a été
sur l'ensemble des politiques il y a
deux pistes la première c'est de bien
vérifier que conformément aux
engagements qui ont été pris les agences
de l'eau mobilisent les crédits
supplémentaires qui étaient prévus au
niveau national c'est-à-dire 70 million
d'euros par an deuxième élément de
regarder aussi dans la politique
agricole ce que sont les relicat mais
Monsieur Benoît pardon de vous dire que
les relicat ne les connaî qu'en fin
d'année donc j'essaie de faire des
prévisions nous sommes mobilisés vous le
savez mais je peux pas inventer des
dispositifs tant que je ne regarde pas
ce qui est dans la PAC possible et
capable d'être mobilisé puis
pardonnez-moi de le dire l'État s'était
mobilisé autour des régions je suis sûr
que les régions se mobiliseront autour
de ce sujet là la région Bretagne en
particulier pour trouver des solutions
budgétaires faut pas toujours tout
demander à l'État merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le
ministre la parole est à madame la
Présidente Chatelin pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la présidente
Madame la la première ministre en 2014
Robert baninter écrivait 70 ans se sont
écoulés depuis la nuit de l'occupation
les crimes nazis et de leur complices de
Vichy le temps de l'histoire a succédé
au temps de la mémoire les derniers
témoins vont disparaître à leur tour et
l'antisémitisme est toujours vivant oui
l'antisémitisme est toujours vivant la
recrudescence des actes antisémites en
France nous le rappelle cruellement 819
actes antisémites ont été recensés ces
trois dernières semaines c'est deux fois
plus d'actes antisémite que sur la
totalité de l'année 2022 à Paris dans
les hautes scènes et en scène
Saint-Denis ce sont des dizaines et des
dizaines d'étoiles de David qui ont été
taguées sur les murs des immeubles à
villeurbane c'est une synagogue qu'on a
menacé d'incendier à Paris une mésousa
fixée à la porte d'un appartement a été
brûlée ces actes intolérables
s'attaquent à notre pacte républicain
ces actes antisémites décomplexés et
nausés à bond contreviennent à l'article
1er de notre Constitution la France
assure l'égalité devant la loi de tous
les citoyens sans distinction d'origine
de race ou de religion elle respecte
toutes les croyan madame la Première
ministre le 10 octobre dernier vous avez
déclaré dans dans cet hémicycle ne
toléer aucun acte aucun propos
antisémiste et je voulais vous dire dans
cette lutte vous avez le plein et entien
soutien des
écologistes nous avons nous allons
devoir traiter la racine du mal ce qui
caractérise l'antisémitisme c'est la
permanence de la stigmatisation et nous
avons blessé baissé les bras aujourd'hui
les actes que nous connaissons sont les
conséquences d'une longue banalisation
de la parole antisémite et raciste le
négationnisme de Jean-Marie Le Pen le
rémisionisme d'Éric Zemmour
l'antisémitisme complotiste de Dieu
donné et de Soral madame la Première
ministre je conclurai avec les mots et
la question de Robert banater il en va
de l'antisémitisme comme du racisme ce
sont des poisons de la République à une
certaine dose elle en meurt alors madame
la Première ministre comment éradiquer
cette violence et dissiper
l'ignorance merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente cyiel châelin je vais le
redire très clairement rien ne justifie
l'antisémitisme rien n'excuse
l'antisémitisme jamais et je sais que
ces propos madame la Présidente vous les
partagez et je peux vous assurer qu'avec
mon gouvernement nous sommes déterminés
à mener une lutte implacable contre
l'antisémisme contre l'antisémitisme et
vous l'avez rappelé madame la présidente
châelin depuis les attaques terroristes
du 7 octobre sur Israël nos concitoyens
Juifs vivent dans l'angoisse depuis le 7
octobre comme je le disais plus de 850
faits antisémites ont été recensé et
près de 6000 signalements ont été faits
en ligne nous ne laisserons rien passer
madame la Présidente ni la haine sur la
voie publique ni la haine sur les
réseaux sociaux ni celle qui se
dissimule derrière l'antisionisme c'est
pourquoi des consignes de vigilance ont
dès le 7 octobre été passés au préfets
et aux forces de l'ordre c'est aussi
pourquoi les préfets ont dans certains
cas pris des interdictions de
manifestation pour prévenir tout
dérapage ou trouble à l'ordre public la
situation au proches Orient ne doit être
le prétexte à aucune tentative de
récupération aucune volonté d' les
haines ou de souffler sur les
braises l'antisémitisme est un poison
nous savons tous où il peut mener alors
ensemble nous devons le combattre avec
la plus grande force et la plus grande
détermination et je sais pouvoir compter
sur vous madame la Présidente comme je
sais pouvoir compter sur l'ensemble des
députés qui partagent les valeurs
républicaines plus encore face aux
tension internationale nous avons chacun
un rôle à jouer pour apaiser et faire
nation je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la Première ministre la séance
des questions au Gouvernement est
terminée la séance est
suspendue